Kellen,
you could sing us
alive.
That's it.
All right.
We went on the air.
Good evening everybody.
This is a,
if you're listening to
this for the first time,
this is what's called a
fight companion podcast.
And what that means is we don't really
talk about anything that's going to
expand your mind or if we do,
it's totally by accident.
Okay?
We don't talk about,
uh,
there's how many sponsors
we caveman coffee tee shirts
on caveman coffees on bar
buddy tape.
Fletcher Jardeen too.
Awesome.
Tudes
as long as it was like medium,
so I can bust out of it.
We might lead a little gay if we all
got him on what I'm saying to my party.
We're trying hard.
Um,
we can't wait.
We're going to go into this podcast.
What we're going to do is we're
gonna Watch some old school fights,
but we can't,
uh,
we can't really talk about fights until
we talk about our last podcast together
because it kind of became the biggest
podcast in the history of MMA.
How many you can take,
you can take kind of out of that sentence.
Yeah.
It's off the charts off the charts,
Jamie.
It's not ours.
It's theirs.
It's a,
it's a fighter.
And the kid,
these fucking,
oh
no,
we just did in his studio.
We had Joe on and this studio.
But your podcast.
Right,
exactly.
And,
and so Joe kind of spoke,
his mind would just sit there
and neither one of us actually.
Yeah.
And then it's just a chair.
She watched it.
I watched it but youtube and I thought
the whole time it was jre probably that
whole tickets.
It's the same studio.
That's all I was sitting in there.
It would look like the same show.
You can just do it.
Be a red behind me instead of a,
if you yeah,
Brian behind there you would go,
what?
The what the fuck?
Anyway,
now and he's all concerned with them.
Like just Eddie Bravo might be a little
high talk shit could go off the rails.
All I wanted to know is the views,
what kind of feature to the New Yorker
magazine and it got all this stuff.
We're number one on,
on every chart on the dunes.
So it was a blessing in disguise.
But it's huge though.
It's huge.
It was great for Brian Right now.
It was great.
It was great for your podcast and
in a lot of ways it's an important
conversation that needs to be had
about MMA and about fighting gree.
Part of the issue with it was having it
having a really honest conversation in
front of the whole world.
That's part of the issue with it.
If I could do it again,
I definitely wouldn't have done that.
Um,
the good part about doing that is that
it gets this conversation out there.
The bad part about doing that
is you took a lot of heat and I,
I feel real bad for that.
I feel like I really fucked up for that
and I didn't go into that and tending to
like approach it like that.
But it seemed like when we
started talking I started worried
more worried that your perception of like
how the fight went down and the future
and what's going on as far as like the
amount of damage that you've taken is
very different than how I see it and
how a lot of other people see it.
And I think there's a certain
number that every fighter has,
you know,
like a certain amount of times they can
get hit a certain amount of concussions
they could face.
And if I don't know a guy and I see that,
I just know,
okay,
this guy's Chiney,
you know,
and I've called a lot of fights like that.
I've called a lot of fights where
I know if this guy gets tagged,
he's,
his legs are going to go,
you know,
we've all seen it.
We know and I've called a lot of
fights where a guy was a young,
fresh fighter and then I've called
the same guy fighting seven,
eight years later,
six years later,
whatever.
And it's a different human being.
Um,
it's everyone's choice and I'm not
trying to impose anyone's choices or my
choices on anyone else,
but
there's some things that we've talked
about and one of the things that we've
talked about before is you,
you were talking really open and honestly
about some of the losses that you had.
And you said,
why didn't anybody tell me?
You kept saying that?
Why didn't anybody tell me this kid down?
Tell him,
why didn't anybody tell me I shouldn't
be fighting Nogueira my third,
my air time out.
Yeah,
you were like,
I thought it was going to kick his ass.
I thought,
you know,
why didn't anybody tell me?
And you,
you kept saying that it was funny
and you were being self deprecating,
joking around you being self
deprecating is very funny.
But one of the things that uh,
you know,
you see time and time again about being
a fighter is that that same kind of
belief in yourself that makes you want
to get into that fucking cage in front of
the world,
in your underwear and throw
bones at some other dude.
That same kind of belief in yourself can
get in the way if things aren't going
right.
It's almost like so many fighters like
have this ability to put blinders on and
not see the danger and not see,
do not see what other
other people are saying and
is as a person who is
around it all the time,
it gets,
it gets super disturbing.
Like you see it time and time again.
You know,
one of the best things that Dana white
ever did in all the Times that I've known
him is stopped chocolate
Dell from fighting.
It's one of the best things
he ever did because it was,
he could have made a fucking fortune off
chocolate Dell just pair them up with
someone who's not going to knock them out,
pair him up with some dude's
going to grapple with them,
pair him up with some dude,
you know,
uh,
who's not a,
not a big striker guy,
was a real good wrestler.
You know,
there's,
there's guys like that out there.
You should find a comeback opponent for
chuck and just make ungodly amounts of
money.
Rich Franklin wasn't supposed
to be that dangerous on his feet,
you know,
it was like you'd think,
okay,
chuck can out strike.
Frankly,
that's a good,
good fight for sure.
And then what we saw was as
rich Franklin dropped him,
you know,
and it's,
it's,
Joe has seen what he's
talking about when he sees,
when he meets all these guys,
the new fresh crop from tough,
oh,
here's the new guys.
I would,
when I worked with Joe,
I would watch tough cause
it was entertaining but also
to remember all these new
guys that I'm going to meet backstage,
I'm going to meet all these dude I worked
with the UFC eight years and you meet
this new crop,
these new fighters and you feel like
you have to be on top of everything.
They'll,
it's embarrassing when one of these new
guys from the ultimate fighter season
six,
season seven,
six today,
they come up to you backstage and
you have no idea who they are.
There was a couple of seasons that
I missed and it's embarrassing,
right?
You see them come and go and
Joe really is concerned when,
when he see,
when he meets a guy and they
come in and like he sees like,
man,
how much damage is this going to take?
Uh,
is this guy going to be one of the elite
than make it through or is it going to
be like most fighters that don't go
all the way through and then they go
through,
they go through some
tough times and all that.
I S I see the exact same thing,
but I look at it just a little
bit different because I,
I think,
hey man,
you know it's dangerous.
You're getting in the,
in the octagon.
If you wanna,
if you wanna put your brain in jeopardy,
go for it.
I look at it as why these guys
came in and why they got cut.
Like when you look at all these fighters,
they get,
why did he get cut?
Why did he lose that last
fight that got him cut?
I'm always looking at what,
who's trainers war?
What does training was?
What does Jujitsu was like,
who was he training with his wrestling
and as for investing and striking and
what went wrong there.
And cause most people
that come into the UFC,
Devin even get to the main card.
Most people that are,
don't,
aren't even aware of these hundreds of
fighters that come through never make it
to the main card and they're gone.
They're cut you out.
You lose two fights in a row.
In the prelims they're
going to cut you generally.
Right?
But you know how many wins you have to
line up in a road to get to the main
card,
especially if you're under one 70 you
have to put like eight or nine wins
together before it's like,
it's like getting,
getting into the UFC,
getting signed by the UFC is easier than
going from the prelims to the main guy.
[inaudible] back.
The easy part happened,
you got signed with UFC,
here comes the hard part.
Let's see you last,
I was going to say it to
piggyback on that and I think what you
are saying and what I took away from it
was was the fact that look,
to get to the belt,
you are going to have to take a certain
number of fights and just because of the
way this sport is,
you're going to take damage
no matter who you are.
And the question is,
is it worth it?
And you were speaking
specifically to Brenton,
is it worth it to go through that
journey,
go through that journey and possibly do
real damage to yourself when there's a
bridge to cross that and,
and I that I took.
So I think that's a question that
every fighter has to ask themselves.
Um,
and I think it requires being
very honest with yourself.
So that's kind of what I,
that's what I,
why I thought the conversation was
very relevant to anybody who is in,
in combat sports.
Look at your look at your brain this way.
Okay.
Pretend your brain is a rock,
that you're going to carve a sculpture of.
Okay.
And you're chipping.
You want to do,
if you have one sculpture that you can
make with your whole life with this
brain,
you want to make the very
best sculpture possible.
You can't chip too much shit away from
it and then try to put rock back on.
It doesn't work.
You only have a certain
amount of rock to work with.
And I look at fighting in the same way.
You have a certain amount of brain that
you could take damage with before you,
you start seeing weird shit with guys.
You start seeing guys get
knocked out by punches.
It looked like nothing.
You start seeing guys,
uh,
just a normal shot that
they would have taken.
You saw this with chuck
in his early career.
He would eat nothing like candy and
just blast you right in the face.
Like it was nothing.
It was very demoralizing when guys would
fight chuck cause they would clip him
right in the Chin and he would
just fucking break your face in.
I mean he just was so tough,
so tough and so mean.
You know when chuck,
I mean it's a very nice guy but when he's
competing he was just for Rosha and he
was also known for
having any credible chin.
Incredible Chicken Club,
which,
and he went from having one of the best
chins in the game and we saw it to man.
He went through what
most fighters go through.
A lot of fighters,
the,
they go through their career and they
try to piece things together as it goes
along.
Try to get,
well,
you know,
maybe I should,
uh,
you know,
work with more wrestlers
and maybe I should,
uh,
work with,
good kickbox and coach
or it's f I believe.
I really strongly believe in this,
that in the future we're going to have,
every fighter is going to have like a
Matt Hume or for Rasa Hobby or a guy like
that who's like a maestro,
a guy who looks at you actively.
And those are the best
guys out in my opinion,
those two guys.
There's a few other guys that
John Crouch is great at it,
but a guy who looks at you
objectively and finds what's wrong,
what's right and moves you into position
slowly gets you fights with the right
caliber opponent and gets you
to a place where you need to be.
Very few guys have the luxury that
very few guys ever get to that.
And I think that along the way a lot of
guys take some damage in training that's
unnecessary or that they
could have avoided they.
And then you know,
you,
you factor in life,
you know,
you factor in like with you especially
you factor in how many years of football?
20 how many time do you
think you got your bell rang?
20 years of football.
Maybe six.
That's it.
Yeah,
like flat lined or just,
no.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's,
that's how many times
you get hit in the head.
The other thing that goes on in football,
it's really crazy that people don't
think about its chest when you're going
chat.
When you get hit in the chest,
it seems like an impact
that's just on your chest,
but a large amount of concussions,
even concussions at windup in depression
or from chest injuries from getting hit
in the body because your brain and you
snap back your head even though you're
not getting hit in the head,
your brain smashes around inside of your
head and it causes some serious injury
to the brain and they're,
they're doing all these
different tests on like,
like what is important?
Is it head contact,
his head moving.
A lot of soccer players have issues with
the CTE as they get older from heading
the ball,
just heading a fucking rubber ball.
It that much doesn't matter.
And it was not,
it doesn't,
it's not.
It's,
yeah,
they do a lot,
but it's a matter of that,
that thump,
that jolt,
that sharp jolt.
It's your brain moving around inside
of your head and it's not designed for
that.
And at a certain,
it has a certain amount of those you can
give it and then it just starts going.
It's like a fucking transmission that
you just jam into fucking first when
you're on the highway.
After a while,
it's that thing.
It's just like,
whoa.
Hey,
hey,
hey gears.
Start breaking.
Shit starts falling off.
If I didn't know you and you were just
another fighter and you asked me for
advice,
I'd probably be a lot nicer
about how I gave you that advice.
I did that cause I'm fucking terrified
I did that because I'm seeing you're a
smart dude.
You're a funny dude and you're,
you're like fun to be around.
We're not going to go.
That goes with no,
no,
no.
We're going to good place if that,
if that goes away,
I would be horrified.
I'd be fucking horrified.
I would have a real problem.
I've had problems call and
fights with people I barely know.
And then I see them get to
that point where they're,
they're,
they,
they start slurring and they
started having a hard time.
I see it in interviews.
I see them like struggle in interviews.
I go,
Ooh,
look at him.
And sometimes it's just a guy's tired.
That's possible.
Shit.
If you catch me,
if I'm really tired,
you know,
in some of the interviewed me,
I bet I'd probably look
like I was fucked up.
You can usually,
but there's,
there's just a thing
that happens where I go,
fuck,
he's gone.
You know,
and I,
I've seen too many guys,
man.
I've seen too many guys.
I seen a bunch fighting his
fucking dangerous as shit.
But it's more dangerous when
you're not considering the danger.
It's like,
you know,
Tj grant guy was fighting
for the lightweight title,
has a title shot lined up,
smashing everybody and it looks fantastic,
has one concussion and
all of a sudden he can't,
he can't recover from
this fucking concussion.
He's got to look this year long.
Headache is all fucked up,
tries to get back every time he
tries to get back to the gym,
tries to start training again,
fucks him up again.
And he's like,
this might,
you know,
he's,
he's trying to figure out what to do.
Like this might be over,
he was in line for a title
shot a year and a half ago,
something like that.
A year and a half million.
And then the guy who was
fighter who fought before he
got that shot of the title
is Gray Maynard,
uh,
gray Maynard with grain or is
a fucking animal guy comes off.
Tough,
tough wrestler,
a hard punch,
you know,
but it goes through these wars.
She got wars with Frankie Edgar.
He started off with a great chin too.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
the side,
the last fight when Nate Diaz,
he gets tagged and he just,
his body freezes.
You could tell,
you could see it in his face.
His body freezes and he like this guy
just is not taking shots the way he used
to tag them,
you know,
and maybe he's okay.
Maybe you know,
he went into that fight.
That's the other thing guys go
into fight with injuries already.
Like you were talking about,
um,
your fight with Ben Rothwell,
the UN,
that fight we were talking
about on the podcast,
you'd got tagged by Corwin and training
up to that and you're going in already
diminished.
You going in like with
a weakened chin already.
We,
you know,
if somebody tags you,
you're already,
it's like you hurt your knee.
So when he gets you in a knee bar
and your knees tweaked already,
like you're fucked.
That's,
that's the same way with everything
Brandon.
I mean if you decided or are you like on
the fence or you for sure fighting for
sure.
Fighting,
not even up for discussion.
Yeah,
I mean you guys can keep talking about it.
Sure.
At this point,
at this point.
That's defensive Brendan Tone know
at this point it would be about,
I think,
uh,
it's,
if Brian started hanging out with any
other fighter who just got into the UFC,
whoever it was,
there's a good chance,
80% chance.
I would say that we'd be going
through the exact same thing at,
at whenever a,
that person's career,
you know,
whenever there was like two or
three losses and are big losses,
Bam.
That would mean if you're around Brian,
that means Joe likes you too and what
you're hanging out and he gets to know you
and,
and he's just,
it really is.
I know,
you know this,
it really is just him like loving you.
That's all it is.
Zero fence for me.
For me,
I'm like,
man,
if you want to still fight,
this is what I think.
I think you,
if you just say fuck the brain injury,
I don't give a shit.
I'm going,
I'm going for,
I'm a fucking savage and this
is what I was born to do.
I don't care if my brain
starts going bad at at 50.
If you're going to do that,
then this is,
this is what I would say,
just
get out of here,
Scott,
free every now and then.
Every now and then someone,
some fighters asking me for advice,
what they should do and,
and everything that he said about like,
you know,
like your footwork for example,
and kind of lunging with your punches.
Yeah.
Obviously you're not as smooth
as Anderson Silva on your feet.
That's obvious.
The goal I would say,
if you're going to keep going,
okay,
let's fucking get that
foot work and the movement
down,
let's strive to move.
Like,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
John Jones,
whatever John Jones has stolen,
however he's moving.
Maybe you'll never be Jon Jones,
but you strive for excellence.
Maybe you get halfway there,
but you're in,
in your pursuit,
you get 70% of the way there.
But I think you're a,
you're a tremendous athlete.
You play football,
you can do anything.
Um,
I think,
you know,
just critiquing your last fights,
it's like spend extra time getting
your footwork professional,
rocky three,
Rocky Balboa,
Mr t,
watch that movie.
You know what I mean?
[inaudible]
was about about him getting
his foot work together.
He gets his footwork together
and then he beats Mr t get,
you can get smooth if you remember it.
Anybody can do it.
If you pay attention to
fiber Eastover doing.
For instance,
right now,
he's a killer.
Stryker with great footwork
and great movement.
He's fucking people up.
But he wasn't like that for awhile.
He was the classic Jujitsu guy like
Hadzic Gracie when he came out,
super good Jujitsu Guy,
they'd had zero stand up and there they,
you don't think I take one
punch that really shaky.
They're trying to get
the fight to the match.
They lose,
lose some decisions that get taken down.
You know,
the,
they really don't have anything
to offer on their feet.
Right.
So,
but then you,
what Felicia over doom did than most
other Jujitsu fighters didn't do a lot of
judges to fighters.
They poked him into the MMA world.
I,
you know,
on this is gonna take way
too long to way too scary.
Like I'm going to open up an
academy and fucking make money.
Just [inaudible] a lot of guys that
did that and some Jujitsu guys have,
you know,
they,
they lasted a few fights,
but they can never get
their stand up together.
They,
it was started looking okay,
but then it was just condemn and then
they didn't have the wrestling to take
down these wrestlers.
So they're stuck standing and they
can't take these wrestlers down there,
not that pro pulling guard.
So they get caught in this mess
and then they get cut in the UFC,
UFC,
all these black belts in,
out,
in,
out and out by bt.
Super Doom and out.
But you know what?
He stuck it out.
He stuck it out camp
working on his footwork,
kept working on a strikes,
the power and the combinations.
Look at Fabius we're,
we're doing now.
He stuck it out.
People don't remember those dark
ages he started working with,
he wasn't that good.
His standup wasn't that
good and it takes so long.
I just think you gotta get the ultimate
standup coach do you could find,
and it was just like rocky three,
the focus on lids and then work with,
um,
I would just,
just as someone who's giving you advice,
find the best wrestler wrestling team,
go to Colorado and get your wrestling
on trying to strive for Olympic level.
You might not get there,
but you're an athlete.
You can get real.
Could be an amazing wrestler.
You could be an amazing striker.
You think you can throw all those
spinning kicks and heel kicks.
Yes,
you can.
You just gotta practice.
You can do anything you want every time.
Every time we've had discussions like the,
it seems like you,
you think,
um,
that a lot of techniques
or just for certain people,
for their body types.
I believe you can do anything you want.
I believe you can.
I paid them before,
locked down and no,
seriously this,
the real and then,
and then the Jujitsu,
that Jujitsu you need to not to,
to release the stuff.
That's that.
That's that whole whatever is keeping
you from opening your mind to the best
possible Jujitsu every seen Ben
Saunders his last fight with drill rigs,
oil rigs.
He heard a snap from a takedown,
but you just see how Ben Saunders
was about to eat him up right away.
You just see that you can do that.
I'm not just blowing smoke up your ass.
You could do all that.
Then Saunders came down for
three weeks and I ran it.
People are going to be shocked
when they see him when they buy,
if that fight wouldn't have ended.
Oh Man.
The position we worked on,
Joe rigs just fell right into it.
He,
he was about to light them
up with amazing guard word.
Uh,
Ben Saunders.
A lot of guys have come through my
gym and have a lot of great fighters,
but Ben Saunders is the only fighter
ever that I ever worked with.
The came to me or Ricardo
laboriel black belt.
He's already good at on
the ground and he's all,
he has a lot of MMA experience and he's
a great striker with super long legs.
He's six three,
but has the legs held,
his legs are insane and super flexible.
I,
someone just gave me the,
if I said it was perfect,
they gave me a guy to get his rubber
guard together who's already a dangerous
striker,
long and Lanky,
super flexible.
Already a black belt in Jujitsu,
man,
Ben Saunders is a,
is a,
is going to shock the world.
And I believe,
I believe you give me three weeks,
just come to my gym.
I'm not going to charge you.
It's still,
you know,
I'm not saying leave Henner Gracie,
just train with Henner.
He's got a lot of great stuff.
Henna Gracie has great stuff.
He's the great grandson of Haley.
Oh,
come on,
give me a break.
He's very super knowledgeable,
right?
All but you can always add to your game.
You could always add weapons.
And that's the mindset I believe
every fighter should have,
including you always.
It's like,
what weapons can I add in wrestling?
Oh,
I'm done with the wrestling.
You're not done with the wrestling.
You need more setups.
You need,
uh,
a master wrestling off the fence and
really turn that into an arc on Jujitsu.
There's so much you can cad,
dude,
there's so much you can add.
Talk to Ben Saunders.
Talked to Tony Ferguson.
Yeah.
When guys actually opened
their mind and come through,
man,
my,
my team,
you know,
we're all working together to come up
with the best possible Jujitsu for MMA
possible.
We're getting a little off track.
I agree with you.
In on all points was about
Brendan has really good Jujitsu.
You definitely could benefit
you to work at guard,
but you're striking.
If I had to say one thing to you when we
talked about this before or right after
their Alaska fight,
I'm like,
you got to
go and do like some hardcore like go to
some like really elite gym and have a
guy like Henri Hooft or have a guy
like rob came in or have Duane Ludwig.
Have someone work with
you for a long time.
Have someone tighten up all 30.
Dude,
you're young.
You can take a year or two off and you
see somewhat funniest fuck 30 as young as
fuck.
You look like you're 24 did
and you're in great shape.
It wouldn't be a bad idea.
You know,
if I read tomorrow that you
just wrote a blog and you said,
you know what,
I decided I'm going to take two
years off to get my striking to the,
I'm not going to come back until
my striking look beautiful.
I'm,
I'm going to go to Thailand for
fucking six months or whatever.
Just the focus,
the focus should be the foot
work and the combos and,
and the,
the arsenal,
the leg kicks a flying knees.
Brendan,
what's your thoughts on the podcast and
the aftermath and all that shit cause
we're just talking at you here.
I don't know where to start.
I mean,
uh,
people think I was like offended or they
thought we were mad at each other and
that it couldn't be
further from the truth.
I know you're looking out for me.
It's all the only reason I know this.
I wasn't man the least bit.
There's maybe five people in this world
who could talk to me that way and I went
and try and kill,
you know what I'm saying?
So,
uh,
you're one of them and uh,
I dunno man,
during the,
it's tough to listen to,
you know,
I stopped to listen to them.
People are like,
Oh,
you took it great.
Nah,
man,
I didn't know what to do.
I wish I could take that credit
trying not to cry to be honest.
That's why I was just going,
uh,
because I was,
if I would have said more than that,
I would just start crying and
then people are texting me like,
my brother's like,
dude,
just fucking leave.
This is brutal.
Like,
well,
I can't do that.
What you mean brother also told
you that he agreed with me?
Yeah.
He agrees to.
As far as he,
he,
he thinks I can be champ.
I could fight for a title,
but he thinks that I could make more
money being a doing podcasts in my shows.
But he's also worried about you?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He's like,
I don't want to see you
get punched in the face.
Yeah,
yeah.
He doesn't think I'm like
washed up and I'll shitty.
Like you really could become
like you guys together,
especially as a team.
You guys can become a huge force.
That's the other thing.
Like,
like you're hilarious,
like doing,
doing this,
doing the podcast with you is by far by
far the biggest thing we've ever done.
And just the notoriety and the
amount of love I get now is insane.
Like I,
I was walking down the street from
Starbucks and this construction workers,
three of them came up to
me and gave me a big hug.
Like,
don't stop man.
We love you man.
Don't stop.
Like,
it's insane.
And then you see the
article in the New Yorker.
I mean,
it's just the coverage we got from it.
And honestly,
when I left here,
I texted Brian right away.
I said,
we're not posting that man.
I'm super embarrassed.
I'm crying right now.
Do not post.
And I got home again,
cried some more,
and I was like,
I think you and I started talking.
And,
uh,
I was like,
yeah,
we probably should post it
because there's an unselfish way.
I've had a lot,
I'm not going to mention names.
I've had a lot of fighters
reach out to me who were like,
thanks dude,
like that.
That went a long ways man.
I needed to hear that.
I can't believe you've stood in,
took it like a man,
blah blah blah.
So I have these people who are in the
business reaching out to me now and I have
big shoulders,
man,
have thick skin.
I'd be shorts for a reason cause
they can take all this shit.
You know what I'm saying?
It,
I took it as you just reaching out to me.
So we spoke about,
hold on top that I'm talking.
I was going to say what he said about,
we talked about releasing it and
you kind of said this is part of,
this is part of my thought process.
This is part of the experience of fighting
and that's why he kind of decided why
hide this?
Let's not to let this out there and
get the debate I talked about on our
podcasts.
Like it's like a journey.
Like the reason the show so big and the
reason why when you do a show I walk in,
people are cheering big brown.
It's insane man.
When I,
when I go to anything.
So the reason why is because they're
on this journey with me like they care,
like they literally care about me.
So I talk about signing a fight.
I talked about getting the trash,
Brown fight,
how excited I am.
I tell you about going through
training camp and the buildup,
how excited and nervous and scared
and then after the fight win or lose,
there's still a part of this journey.
So I'm just going to leave it.
And this was a huge part of it.
Good or bad.
It does.
I think it does wonders for not only
me but other fighters out there or
football.
I've had football guys reach out to me.
I had a ton of people reach out to me and
thank me for having that conversation.
Both fighters,
trainers,
former fighters,
just across the board.
You know,
so many people don't want
to have that conversation.
They just don't because we all know it's
real and it's the monster in the room
that nobody talks about you.
You know what it has done though.
It's like a,
you know,
obviously you're a powerful dude,
but I don't think you realize
on when you say something,
these fucking people jump on it man.
But it's opened up a weird door because
people don't realize that you and I are
good friends.
They think,
you know,
like they see me on here whatever,
six times a year,
whenever the fuck I'm here.
So they think we're just whatever.
And you call my fights in the UFC.
So it's opened up this door
where like the fucking guy at uh,
uh,
Bennigan's or whatever.
I hop my waiters like,
yeah,
man,
heard the podcast.
I think,
uh,
I think you might want to give it up
for sure.
Starts with,
I think,
yeah,
for sure.
Go get my double stack,
but thanks.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like,
so it's opened up a weird doorman where
I'm telling you I've had close family
and friends,
like,
wow,
what you need to do.
They think because I
took the advice thing.
Everyone thinks I took it well
when I was just trying not to cry.
They,
they offered me the advice now where
they've never been a fight in their life
like a at a family member go,
I just don't get why you
don't do two week camp.
I mean you do these eight week camp,
you seem overtrained let's just
go two weeks and then people are
giving you that kind of advice because
they sat down at two oh five why did they
come up with a two week camp?
No one's ever said that.
No,
it's insane.
They'd never been a fight.
Can you make two or five?
I don't know.
One day somebody,
somebody close to him said go down
to two or five and fight in February.
He was like two and it's opened up.
It's opened up this door
where people are like,
oh,
shopping cart,
the likes this.
I'm just going to give them advice.
If you're changing my oil for sure.
Don't give me funding advice
so it's open like that door.
You know what I'm saying?
It's whatever people
love you that were good.
People love me.
I,
I've had a conversation with Dwayne and,
uh,
listen,
Austin Peay,
I've had conversations with
people that don't like you.
And I say it's because you don't know.
That's it.
I'm like,
if you know him and you don't like me to
take a page out of Brendan Schaub lose
my number.
If you know me,
you don't like them.
If you know Brendan Schaub,
you don't like him if I don't
know if I said that right,
but don't,
yeah,
you're wrong.
You're a real nice guy.
And you know,
and I think that's one
of the hard things about,
um,
being in a position where you're,
you're exposed to the public because
you're just going to get a bunch of
opinions you're going to,
but I get it no matter what,
anything I talk about,
it's a,
it's one of the weirdest things.
Like you'll be in line at Starbucks and
someone will try to bring up some shit
that happened to you,
like some personal shit from
like 10 years ago or something.
And I'll talk to you about it.
Like,
yeah,
I heard you bring him to you talking
about this and that and blah,
blah.
He's like,
dude,
I'm just trying to get a coughing.
Get out of here.
We're not going to go into
some weird shit about my dad.
You know?
I don't know you.
This is crazy.
He's cause that,
talk about some shit
and I think you mean a way.
Yeah,
in a way.
But you don't know someone
unless they know you too.
You do know them,
but you don't know them in terms of like
how you guys interact with each other,
especially if not accusing
these people being clueless.
But if you run into a clueless person,
they think they have this idea of
who you are based entirely on your
interactions with other people.
They're not taking into account
how that person would react to you.
Like you know,
you think you have this idea of who
the fuck Brian Callan is and how to fix
Brian Cowen.
But Brian County will be like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
How about you look in a mirror,
motherfucker.
You know you're talking
all this shit about me.
Why don't you look at yourself like this
is a crazy conversation that you're not
qualified to be doling
out advice to Brian can.
That's why podcasts are so big
and that's why people buy it.
Because those same people are going to
listen to every show you do what Rogan
says,
Brennan shop needs this.
Listen,
I run them and like,
yeah man,
you need to do this road,
this man.
It's a numbers thing.
I mean you're dealing with millions of
people now and when you're dealing with
millions of people,
you're gonna run into a certain amount
that are just crazy and a certain amount
that overstep boundaries and asserting
them out there just getting real nervous
around you and they,
they,
they talk out of character
when they're around you.
That would never bough too.
Especially if they're drinking.
How many fucking drunk dudes have
got me and bear hugs and pick me up.
Fuck crazy.
Drag me over to their friend's mean.
People lose their shit.
They didn't know what to do.
They are like that.
They've grown up with you
in a way like in some way.
Yeah,
they get drunk and you know,
just,
it's overwhelming.
And I've,
I've experienced it,
I've been lit up for,
and I met someone that I
really admire and like,
Whoa,
this is fucking die.
And you know,
you,
you know,
the only time I ever experienced anything
close to real faith was when I did one
episode of sex in the city
when it was the biggest show.
And I walked through
New York City and I am,
I am nodding,
I was with Jimmy Burke
and I am not exaggerating.
Literally every woman that came by,
every woman was like,
oh my God,
you were so funny.
Last night I started dragging
Jimmy into bars just to see,
just to have this experience.
I was like,
women and girls would get drunk.
They dragged me and I was a prop.
I was basically a prop.
They didn't know my name or anything,
but just,
but we're talking about dudes,
we're talking about
sex and the city better.
It's way better.
Yeah.
Well I'll go places and guys
a think because I'm a fighter.
They'll hit me.
Oh God,
Holy Shit.
Shop and hit me.
I'm like,
I know you don't hit
me mail like to get it.
How many times do people
ask you to take pictures?
Choking them.
I get those.
Mine's more of a punch punch.
I do a terrible choke
just so they can't sue me.
Yeah.
Well you know the UFC actually told
people to not take pictures with people
choking him.
She has chocolate.
Dale and Matt Hughes both got suit.
I tell this to people when they asked
me to take a picture choking them and a
picture,
I say,
I literally can't.
I've been told not to good scam.
Can you take a picture of me choking me?
A guy left a guide to do with Matt Hughes,
listen to this.
And the guy was a fucking bad cop.
The guy was a fucking dirty cop.
So he takes his picture with Matt Hughes.
Mad is choking him in the picture,
you know,
and look,
Matt's a fucking hard ass in a,
in a wrestler and one of the greatest
welterweight world champions ever.
So I'm sure he fucking
really choked this dude.
I'm like,
all right dude.
You want it?
Yeah.
Country fucking farmer strong.
It was like,
all right dude,
you want to get silly.
Just fucking gave him the clamp down,
but he didn't hurt the guy.
At the very least,
the guy got it.
He got to experience what it feels
like to get choked by a fucking world
champion.
So this guy goes and he's
files this lawsuit because
he's got the photo of Matt.
He was choking him.
Meanwhile everybody around
says the guy asked Matt,
he was to choke him in the picture and
then they start looking into this dude
because the dude soon,
Matt Hughes and they find out he's dirties
doing all sorts of illegal shit and
now the guy's in jail.
Oh guy went to jail because of that
shows people in pictures and then chuck
Ladelle wound up,
I believe I might be
talking about a school here,
but I'm almost positive he settled.
I'm almost positive they had to settle
because it was some stupid number,
like 10,000 and the lawyers like,
look,
you're going to spend
25 grand fight in this.
But they use that commercially.
Does that oil filter,
commercial,
whatever it is,
where he's just zoning or some shit.
This is a long time ago.
This is a long time ago while
he was a world champion.
Yeah.
That's crazy man.
Yeah,
it happens all the time.
So what do you,
what do you want to do?
What's your plan?
How are you going to rebound from this?
Uh,
make some changes,
switch some things up.
I'll go over it.
I'll probably off here
what I'm going to do,
but uh,
just make some changes camp wise,
coach wise and um,
just focus on my weaknesses and get
better man where card and then uh,
I'll fight again.
Heavyweight and I would imagine,
uh,
mid next year and what helps me right now,
you know?
Yeah,
I'm in a dark place,
but um,
our podcast,
find the kid and doing stuff
like this really helps me man.
So I'm focused on the podcast.
I've wrote a couple of new segments
and if you can keep this guy in line,
like you guys make them show up
and you guys work together still.
You guys are great team.
It's hilarious.
Team.
You have like a man,
very Brian is,
I count on Brian,
you know,
I mean I goof on Brian all the time,
but when,
when I had this opportunity to
go hunting for that show meter,
it's only one guy called,
cause I know that Brian would go camping,
he'll fucking,
he'll,
he'll sleep in the snow.
Like he's,
he's just,
he just can go through shit.
He ain't calling me.
I called Eddie,
Eddie Bravo be like,
dude,
you can go to the supermart
heading off [inaudible] Brian's.
Brian is there for you too.
And Brian is also never angry
at you and never in a bad mood.
He's a very unique guy,
is a very unique guy.
You know,
like Eddie Bravo and I,
I love Eddie.
He's my pride.
And these guys are both,
they're both my brothers,
but Eddie,
the difference between them is like
Eddie can get upset at people about shit,
but I've never seen you upset
anyone in my life where you're like,
fuck that guy man.
If whatever reason,
whatever you have in you,
you have this weird
thing and you man will,
you just,
you're like a duck.
Water just rolls off your back,
shake that shit and you keep on going.
I can't stay.
It's,
it's an amazing positive quality because
Eddie and I are very similar in a way.
We're both really nice,
but deep,
deep down inside we have some weird
resentment shit because of our dads.
You know,
there's like this anger shit.
We both have one of
this weird abandonment,
anger shit where we're like,
you know,
fuck the world,
you know?
But it's also one of the
reasons why we're brothers.
It's like,
you know what?
I'm like the same with you man.
When we met each other,
we became best friends,
like instantaneous.
I know,
you know,
with you and with Eddie
was exactly the same thing.
Like you,
you could sleep in my house,
you can do whatever the
fuck you want to do.
You want to borrow my car,
you know,
it's instantaneously because we have this,
I know when dudes are real,
you know,
I know when no one's going to fuck me.
I know,
I know when I,
when you have love for someone and you
know it's reciprocated and you know,
I would do anything for you.
You know that.
And I would do anything for you
and I would do anything for you.
It's if I really would.
And so being in this situation where
you're watching someone and they're,
they're going down a path you'd like,
God dammit,
there's a fucking cliff.
How do I tell him there's a fucking cliff
at the end of this shit is a fucking
cliff.
There's a goddamn cliff.
And he's done it.
Especially as someone that,
yeah,
but you know what,
like,
you could,
you could rebound from a lot of the shit,
but someone who's a,
uh,
mixed martial arts fighter,
it's a fucking crazy cliff cause it's,
it just goes,
it just drops off and there's
no pillow at the bottom.
There's no airbag.
And there's ways around
that fucking cliff.
You know,
Matt Hughes,
perfect example,
you talked to him today.
He's sharp as a tack.
He's fine,
he's fine.
And he was never a great striker,
you know,
he never got knocked out or
he got knocked out in the,
in the cage couple of times,
but he never really knocked anybody
out other than Henzel Gracie,
like standing.
Everything was like him taking
guys down ground and pounding him,
you know,
but he,
he got knocked out by Bj.
He got knocked out by
Palae way back in the day.
You know,
he stopped by a few guys.
George Saint Pierre stopped him.
Um,
you know,
he fought some really
fucking bad ass dudes,
but to this day he's fine.
I talked to Matt all the time.
It's a fence.
He was one of those guys that said,
okay,
that's it.
I had a good run.
These new dudes.
Holy Shit.
I'm actually going to have
to learn how to strike,
compete with these guys.
Fuck that.
How about c?
Well,
you know,
there's just,
everybody has,
like I said,
you have a rock.
We're all born with a rock.
Different people's rocks
are different size.
Mark Hunt's rock is as
big as this fucking room.
You know,
he's got a different size of the rock.
Some guys have a rock that's
like really small man.
Some guys rock like you gotta
be careful what your sculpture,
you're designing something and you
should design that to the best of your
possible abilities and with you,
you're a very high profile dude,
not just because of the UFC,
but now because of the podcast.
You have the opportunity.
I mean you could get guys who would be
more than happy to take partial credit
for turning your striking around for
turning you into an elite kickboxer.
Yeah,
Duane Ludwig is the motherfucking man.
Dude.
I mean I'd never met a guy who was
more obsessed with taking fighters and
turning them into like prodigies based
on all of the information that he has in
his head.
He's texted me several times right before
we came in here and we've talked about
it.
Let me,
Dwayne and I have talked about you to
Dwayne and I talked about you before I
brought him in to work with you.
I brought him in to work with
you because I have a deep,
tremendous respect for Dwayne's
knowledge and also his obsession.
Dwayne's a nut.
Really?
He's a nuts.
You get that Tj Dillashaw
foot work together.
You could do that.
It's just going to take a lot of work,
but anybody could do it.
Not only that,
Duane is Dwayne,
doesn't sugarcoat Jack Shit.
Dwayne won't sugarcoat and he
won't even sugarcoat sugar.
You know,
Dwayne's like that's planted sugar.
It is what it is.
You know,
I love you.
You're my mother Fucker,
but this is wrong.
You're lifting your back foot off
off when you throw in right hands.
What the fuck kind of shit is that like
Dwayne will go and then you do it right?
He like,
yeah,
motherfucker,
I kill.
He'll give you all the positive
reinforcement when you do it right,
but if you do it wrong,
Dwayne,
what's a shit in your mouth?
You know,
he doesn't,
he doesn't give a fuck.
You know,
he's a guy who's fought for world titles
and kickboxing was a elite MMA fighter
for a long time,
you know,
has been down.
He's been up,
he's been Kod Kaos guys been submitted,
seen it all.
Yeah,
no crazy.
Would it be if Duane Ludwig
got his shit together?
He's coming out looking smooth.
That would be amazing.
You know,
it's all,
it's all just about numbers.
And I was say that
fighting in a lot of ways,
it's like having a conversation.
Someone could shout you down.
You know someone,
if you don't know how to deal with it,
someone can shout you down.
But if you'd know how to deal with it
and someone tries to shout you down,
you'll like,
you'll slip away and then
they'll get tired of,
and you down and you go,
what did you just say now?
What'd you say?
You basically said nothing and here's why
he said nothing cause you're a fucking
idiot and this is why
you're a fucking idiot.
And then you start hitting him with all
these words that they don't know and all
these sentences they
couldn't possibly form.
And you,
you barrage them with a,
a verbal assault of intelligence and of,
of articulation that
they're not capable of.
And a lot of ways fighting is like that.
There's some guys that could storm out
of the gate and they have one technique
and they throw it out
here and they fucking,
but if you're skilled,
you move and you slip and you slide and
eventually you start Anderson Silva and
a motherfucker.
Like when Anderson Silva
fought Stephan Bonner,
one of the best examples is like
force it guy or Forrest Griffin.
Both of them are good
both to stem the bar.
It was crazy because he backed his
body up against the cage that we,
me and forth.
Oh yeah.
Well he just left for it.
Perfect example in another way in that
forest got Kol dose times in training.
He got knocked out twice in training.
He did.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
you know,
I'm sure had people
telling him to not fight.
You know,
I mean,
I'm sure he,
it's just what you know also forces a
good example of a guy who won a world
title came off the ultimate fighter,
got fed immediately to the dogs.
I mean it was fighting like elite guys,
you know,
like right off the bat.
And then you look at forest now.
I mean for us,
he's physically in a lot of trouble.
Like he can't even brush his
teeth with his right hand.
He's talked about it pretty openly.
He's bodies like really
fucked up his shoulders.
He's taken a lot of
punishment to the head.
He was a big dude to cut to a five though.
Fuck yeah.
That was my size,
if not bigger.
And he said he's a big dude.
So cutting down for that many years.
Really.
Guess who else is?
John motherfucking Jones Jones
walks around two 30 all the time.
It doesn't really.
Yeah,
when Jon Jones is a,
you know,
like when he carries around,
did you get your body fat measured?
What's your body fat?
That was 14% last time was a really,
how long was that ago?
Uh,
who's to eight weeks ago.
How do they do it?
There's some merging you,
uh,
it's with some,
some body composition
machine that scans your body.
Ah,
interests,
fanciest thing.
I would've thought you would've been
higher than that because I'm 17%.
I was 17 or 15%.
But heavyweights.
You know mark hot.
You're pretty
lean.
Well,
yeah.
Yeah.
I think my head is fat out of fat head.
Who's like,
it's him.
I got a couple of big,
my Noggins I probably,
Bravo actually broke.
I put my head next to dean lister.
No,
he's world renowned for
the size of his head.
Yeah,
we took a picture.
He's world renown.
My head's bigger than Dean listers.
Steve Bay MyUsage is getting a good size.
Good Noggin.
I won't cheat.
What did you think watching that fight?
What a God damn slobber knocker steep
bay and junior dos sites and how they can
take that much punishment.
Speaking to pump I jds look stiff.
Yes.
Well,
you know what?
He looked bigger.
What's weird is that he weighed,
weighed the same.
You wait around while he
looked 40 might've been leaner.
Like he look more shredded and this they
just look like he looked perhaps better
to what might've been
leaner John Fish's body.
Did you say John?
I was crazy.
Crazy.
Shredded,
shredded.
I never seen him like
he used to be like Mike.
Just see,
I know I,
he stopped.
He stopped being a Vegan,
started eating meat again.
Oh God.
She'll,
she'll stop being a vegan doe.
He's still a,
and I just talked to him.
What'd you guys think of that?
Uh,
Rusa Mark Paul,
Horace minibar nasty trash dude
monsters and he gets a hold of it.
You know what?
I think,
man,
I think he's held on to submissions
way too long in the past.
But this one was saying it is,
yeah.
People were saying it was too long.
Here's the deal.
If it was any other submission,
it was an arm bar or rear naked choke.
No one have a problem with it.
It's the fact that it's a heal hook and
then it transitioned to a knee bar and
everybody's thinking about their knee
exploding and you know that where the heel
hook,
especially,
you don't have any time,
man,
by the time you're hurting.
Oh Jesus.
Too late.
How has his knee,
it's okay,
right?
It's fucked.
Fucked.
I look at the position as needs in price.
It doesn't mean anything.
Tour,
try to need someone in the face.
They're not holding back.
It's not 80% power.
It's either trying to put
their knee through your faith,
100% power,
as many motherfucking times they
can and the referee stops it.
It's fine.
So when you get injured with,
with little joint locks,
personally for me,
I do Jujitsu.
That's just part of the game.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
He held it on a little bit long,
but that's MMA.
It was a Jujitsu match.
That's a big,
he's so good at that.
His opponent,
his face.
But he didn't even in this fight,
he,
I mean it was like literally
he's holding onto it.
John fitches tapping the referee grabs.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean it's not,
he's in the past held on the shift and
the referees pulling on his arms and he
won't let go.
He doesn't do that.
And then the issue they have is because,
uh,
fitches tapping and you didn't let go.
He doesn't like go to the ref stops you.
You're not supposed to.
Exactly.
What people don't know is in the back.
The Ref says that,
you know what I'm saying?
So he's trained to do that.
He's so strong.
He's five
foot seven and a half
or something like that.
So he's all muscle and all gorilla bones.
And did he see how we
drive the rail tendons?
Did you notice that he pulled guard?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He was not John Fitch down.
He's like,
no,
he needs John Pitch on the ground.
How the fuck is a Brazilian gonna take
a wrestler down if you're not Damien
Meyer,
he's the only guy that's doing it.
You know,
he did it.
You're just like stupid
little single shot.
And then he pulled
guard right into a heel.
So I don't think anybody knows what a
heel hook really feels like until that guy
gets a hold of your legs.
So people that are against
pulling guard right there.
That was a perfect example of
a guy he could not take down,
but he's still got them down anyways.
He's so dangerous.
It's one of those things
that people forget about.
Horrifying.
I was scared.
He's horrifying cause he's
going to mangle your leg.
You're not even gonna train.
Never going to be the same.
You won't even try.
You know what you can be
as they're going to fight.
Rusa Marple,
Horace tap early.
Alan Belcher not only did the best
anybody's ever done at dealing with his
ground game and being caught
up in it and defending,
he also put out a video on
what John Fitch did wrong,
which John Fitch should have done.
Right.
Really?
Yeah,
that,
yeah,
yeah.
He went into the fire and literally
stopped all of Paula Harris stuff.
Literally caught up.
Not too long to see that.
No,
pull it up.
Pull that up.
Uh,
Alan Belcher versus who?
Some Paul.
Yeah.
You put it on that because
we don't want to steal any,
any hitters from your computer.
Oh,
it is.
Okay.
That's right.
Okay,
let's see what we could find it here.
I saw him like two weeks after
that event and I was like,
yeah,
just something like that.
Branding,
just,
just the,
you can get as good with
leg blocks as recent,
more porous.
You can get that good.
And if you are in a situation where you
needed to get this fight to the ground,
the guy was too much
dangerous of the striker.
But you couldn't take him down to him.
Go.
You could pull guard
with those heel hooks.
You can do it.
Anybody can do it.
They just got to work on it.
Yeah.
Let's see this now.
Profit Alan Belcher.
Let me kill us all on this motherfucker.
He's a good dude too.
Yeah,
the Brendan Schaub comeback.
I don't hear anything in this.
This is the first 45 minutes of
the movie rise of the night rising.
Good Brown.
All right.
And then also I'm going to
show how maybe you could get,
do something a little bit better amount
of say John Fish did something wrong.
A lot of people made the same mistake
and a couple of days and look out for it.
So first off,
uh,
probably ours,
the way that he gets to the leg locks a
lot of times is he got the attacks the
legs on a single leg or double
leg and then drops under this.
Take him that he did
and was on the outside.
And then he started lifting the leg
almost like he was going to switch to a
double leg.
And he does it with the perfect Tommy
with a lot of his tech techniques.
He does a really good like set
up by faking the take down.
It lifts a leg or right
when the guy just to it,
that's when he dropped underneath.
Yup.
Right under the leg and
starts to attack the,
the a leg lock right here.
So John Fitch did a good job
to put his weight on the leg and,
and start to go like this.
So my rs locks his legs over here.
Can you come around this side for me?
Alan Belcher really
breaks down who some are.
Paul Horez versus John Fitch.
The knee inside.
I know you're not going
to spell this right.
Alan Belcher.
John Fitch
move and I have it trapped here.
So part of ours continues to twist here
until he finally knocks Fitch down.
And then he starts to attack this hill,
but bringing his wrist underneath here,
but his hand and then pulling on
his hand like this right here.
And what he wants to do is tighten up
the legs and push the toes back and get a
heel hook just like that.
Right.
So what Fitch was doing here was
unraveling his feet a little bit,
openness feed up,
trying to take this off by artist,
wants to bring this over,
just like that.
And he was making space
cutting his knee across,
and then Fitch was also
straightened his leg out.
Okay.
What pilates does though is he
squeezes the knees and he brings this,
he keeps twisting it even though it's
straight and he's expecting the guy to
roll out because the pressure
I'm putting makes them spin.
But as he spins,
I turned back the other way,
which helps break his knee more,
but also puts me right into
a physician for a knee bar.
So now he locks his figure four right
above the knee and he keeps this grew up
here and he can thrust his hips down
while I pull in this street and actually
twist in the hill.
Also at the same time.
It helps if you don't have side a
little bit and you can see in the fight
pirates got on his side.
I think it might've been all the
way go this way to this side here
was actually elevated that he
actually elevated me hands back,
back.
I can feel more room.
It's almost as if I
have this behind my arm.
It shows really strong and I twist
the hill booming and I fussed my hips.
They're getting the tap.
All right.
Okay.
So
they probably too long for us to want
to see what he should have done though.
Yeah,
but this is going to be so long time
for people that are listening to this
podcast.
Go Watch it.
We'll watch it after the show,
but I want to give a,
I also want to get Alan as
many hits on this as possible.
So if you go to Alan Belcher's,
a youtube page,
it's Alan Belcher breaks down who?
Some are Paul Harris.
But this shit is like 1520
minutes long or something.
It actually,
it's only 11 minutes but
pretty dope though.
I'd like to sell it Belcher.
I'd like to see how he defends it.
Who did a better,
no one's a better job at defending
leg locks,
uh,
in,
in the octagon,
in front of the world.
Millions of people pay per view.
Then Alan Belcher,
he rusa,
Marco Horace was all over his legs.
He had five different
intents that his legs.
And what Alan Belcher did is he flew dean
lister in for that camp and he flew in
a guy named Davi Ramos,
who's a leg lock wizards.
And he just had those guys jump on
his legs for two months straight.
And he said the first couple of
weeks he was tapping left and right.
But after a while he
learned how to stop that.
And I have,
and then it just became instinct and
then he became impossible to tap with,
like lost.
So you just have to walk through the fire.
You just have to go through all
those taps and not worry about it.
Just know you're going to get through it.
And no matter what,
no matter what,
unless you have some kind of brain defect,
you put yourself in those
bad spots long enough,
you will figure it out.
It was a stress,
the Ba.
Then after a while you're like,
I don't know.
I'm worried about this at all.
Not only do I not worry about it,
but I'm going to attack from there.
Sorry.
Someone's an alcoholic.
Dee Dee Dee Dee.
I got a drink and a couple of bottles.
Deep Humbug.
Yeah.
Um,
so I think we probably talked enough
about Brendan shop and branch ops career.
I think so.
I love you guys.
Are you guys allowed to pull out,
pull out?
You have to shoot right past fights.
Yeah.
Well,
we're not really watching them.
We're,
we're going to watch.
They're go to the people at home.
I got to see us.
The,
uh,
the video up there is,
we're watched.
See where we're watching w w
what's going on on Youtube.
But once we go to fight pass,
the people at homework is
still going to continue.
We see that we can fight back.
Oh yeah.
We're going to watch the fights.
We're going to watch the fight on
fight pass and I want to watch 'em.
We're gonna Watch some classic fights,
man.
And I want to watch
some early fade or man,
because why early phase such a,
so scary.
The Tyson days.
Good God.
It's time.
This is fade or versus Nogueira.
This is the first one.
And uh,
we can get volume on this,
right?
We can hear it.
So,
so Wilfredo was a sambo world champion.
What is his background?
Combat Samba,
which is a different style.
Sambo.
It's a,
uh,
a samba that also has,
um,
they have a lot of,
uh,
strikes in it and they were the
geek jacket and a head gear.
And I,
you know,
I don't know how long they've
been competing like that,
but it's essentially like
MMA and a lot of ways
I think.
So he's a good fight.
The great fight that he's
kept that have hands in a
good position on the floor.
Look how good he looks.
Handsome bastard back then.
I love that motherfucker know is my hero.
This was 10 years ago.
I think I got a little
bit more technically even
stayed my favorite Brazilian
fighter of all time by
far back in the day.
He was a motherfucker.
He was the first heavyweight that came
along and it showed like real legit
Jujitsu.
His back.
Yeah.
Okay.
We can go through all this.
That'll shut God fatal or
looks yelling to babyface.
Huddle shy.
Not
Missing a lot of the uh,
the big scars that he
developed later in his career.
Yeah,
really bad,
right?
Yeah.
He got Scott some scar tissue,
Russian mafia eyes also.
His body changed.
Yeah.
Look how calm he is.
That was one of the weirdest things
about fate or when he would fight.
That's like Carla Esparza.
Did you see her when she
came out and fought Bros?
Nama jewelry?
Does she actually,
it was,
it was almost,
she was so calm.
If you didn't know that
was like her little thing,
you would think she was petrified.
She was just like the,
yeah,
and rose is all like just dancing
around and just shaking on her side.
Carla's not even moving,
not even an inch.
Look at this shit.
They have the national anthem back then.
Did you remember that?
I don't say that.
That's a booster Martha,
right?
Amarillo Bustamonte Mario
Sperry with fucking black hair.
Look at that.
There's little cheerio.
Cheerio man.
Dude.
Got a nose on
trials off.
It'd be trade shit.
They'd be like,
why did you lose weight?
What happened?
Did you just forget?
I put the pressure on you,
the hips,
or you can get that crowd.
Look how quiet the crowd is.
This is the thing that was weird about
watching fights in Japan when we were
there for the UFC.
Everybody was told me it was like that.
But when you see it live,
and by the way,
they would just,
it,
they've changed since the old days.
The old days it was dead silent.
Now they clap and cheer a little bit
because it's becoming a little bit more
auditions and stuff.
That's trendy thing now.
Damn.
Hold on.
We gotta go to the beginning.
I just want to see,
to take how to fight or to kind of talk.
He doesn't look out and look at it.
He'll get it.
He's tired or back then.
Now.
He never used to look.
He always looks down.
He was thick back then.
It was later in his career
fate or like slimmed out.
He got a lot smaller,
super thick back then.
He sees a lot of kettle bells and
a lot of power lifting back then,
but he decided somewhere along the
line that's skill training was more
important,
but I think that you need both,
man.
I really do.
Oh,
but I mean there's all so many variables
involved in old fader that made him a
monster.
Just a strength is only one of them.
The other thing was just,
he was just so fucking ferocious tiger
mom time and fast too for heavyweight
man,
deceptively fast.
Stand right there.
Look at this.
He also had a really good
technical approach to MMA man.
He just would explode so fast,
so fast,
but he's fucking,
and it's everything he
throws is like a Mac out.
What's the latest?
He's still retired.
He doesn't want to come back.
He's done man.
He's smart.
He knew that those last few fights,
just not the same guys
we're looking at right here.
We're looking at the
dude in his prime here.
This is 2000 for 10 fucking years ago.
Brain was pictures thing is the
2004 there was nobody like him.
Nobody had come along before like him.
Nobody,
nobody could whip off arm bars off their
back the way he could and still throw
fucking serious hands on their feet.
The way he cooks.
I don't think we've seen anyone like him.
As far as the light changes and UFC fight,
his face stays completely the same.
Well he always said that they'll like
showing emotion is showing weakness.
Yeah.
Nogueira with that fucking
wrist control setup,
man,
that was his shit.
He doesn't even look like you warmed up.
Like he just,
he looks cold,
his body like he's just looks like,
eh.
Take my shower.
I was playing cards about 10 minutes ago.
I'm going to fight.
I had to fight hard to see,
you know.
I mean if we remember his
brother and his gnarliest tat,
I was like the grim reaper
holding a baby right now.
He's in jail right now I think for rape.
I don't know if he got out.
His brother did a lot of crazy shit.
There's some video of his
brother drunk off his ass.
Magic.
That guy being drunk and being
mad at you crust raping you
or be mad at you and raping you.
No thank you.
And I mean you
don't even meet a girl.
I've been thinking about as me was framed.
I believe he was framed by the Illuminati.
I think he was going to drop the bomb.
Is that right?
You don't what?
We're going to get some
girls you're fucked.
That's what I,
I don't think he did that.
He was going to drop a bomb about
the CIA's involvement in Oh shit.
Cause cause you want we're listen,
listen failure with some fucking ferocious
ground and pound from inside the big
Nog got those scars from being run over
by a truck I think as a kid was just the
one on his back.
Yeah.
Yeah it is back.
He was in a coma for like a long time
or in the hospital I think for like a
year.
But they do feed him vitamins
and milk won't happen.
Vitamins and milk,
milk,
milk to a baby.
It's bones.
It's got to think about this.
The last thing you want
to give was a baby's milk.
Oh goodness.
I mean it's just what
everybody gives babies.
This is what gay guys love.
This is it.
That's not why they,
why they like him and maybe
cause they think of a fucking,
these guys know that that's aggressive.
Super aggressive.
That's why gay guys like him.
I mean I know a gay man who is a comic
who is very in love with a brand.
And why isn't there Gage Jujitsu?
I mean,
wouldn't you would think
like he's always like,
where's your dad too?
Right?
They probably not enough of them.
Why isn't there more?
Why isn't there a gay Jujitsu Academy?
They're probably,
they would love it.
They would love it.
Can you imagine?
Put out an advertisement,
but even even in the class even engage
you just so you don't think about the
sexual aspect of the positions.
Even engage,
know you don't want
the guy to tap you out.
So even if you are attracted to the guy,
he was dudes beating you up.
I Francis Bacon,
the painter.
I think she gets too important not
to get tapped out that no matter what
position you're in,
you're not picking about sex ever.
You're thinking about
not getting tapped out.
Even if you're gay,
you're not thinking about sex in Jujitsu.
That's what I believe
the move them to some of the
[inaudible] podcast called.
That's what I believe we're
thinking about fighting in the ring,
that they kept moving people to
the center in the same position.
There should.
Good thing about the ring is
that it plays less of a factor,
like as far as the environment.
Then the cage does cause the cage.
You didn't push a guy against it.
It's the whole sport cage wrestling that
is so different than regular wrestling,
wrestling off the cage and all the
possible positions against the cage.
When you're wrestling,
there's only so many positions
against the cage and Kenny Johnson,
he's a wrestler who's
science septic about it.
He trains Alan [inaudible] who's
one of my guys and they're,
oh,
here's a question I have.
If they don't training and mostly
Sam and training in Russia.
He doesn't have a lot of Jujitsu
guys to train with probably.
Right.
So how was he so good at defending against
all these trauma has submissions but
it's not the most of the leg
locks and well their bars.
Farmers especially Camorra's.
Yeah,
which is what it was just going for.
I mean Fado is one a lot of
fight by straight arm bar
and a lot of fights by our
Kimora over doom.
Used to be a cro cups,
Jiu Jitsu instructor.
She what?
Croatia to help him with his defense.
Well even though sambos like a Mo,
it's mostly a leg lock system and catch
wrestling as like this kind of system
without a guard.
Since hoists,
Gracie,
all grappling styles have adopted or
filled the holes that were glaring since
UFC one like oh shit,
we actually do need a guard cause
catch wrestling didn't have a guard.
Eddie,
when you see this,
what do you think here about his guard?
I mean when you see this,
I mean this is obviously 2004 but when
you know your guard and your style,
you mean he must be seeing so
many goddamn openings in this.
It just didn't.
People weren't aware of back then as
far as like when he can control his
posture.
Well,
Nogueira was the first guy to come along
since hoists Gracie to be known for his
guard there we went and hoists Gracie
who tapped everyone out in the beginning
and then people got hip to Jujitsu.
Then they started training it.
They learn the defense and then we had
a long period where like Mark Coleman
came in and the wrestler
started dominating and we
didn't have any Jujitsu guys
in there that knew how to submit people
off their back when there was punches
and elbows and there's no key,
it was just,
it was too much.
It was like a riddle that needed to be
solved and then Nogueira comes along and
boom,
just like that.
He was the only guy out there,
especially especially for a heavyweight
to finish people off their back.
He was known for his guard.
When you talk,
when you're talking about
a MMA guards back then,
most of the time people said
Nogueira had the best guard in MMA.
He was the only guy going after this and
a man fitters getting out of a lot of
stuff.
It's squishy and it's really,
really greasy.
It's greasy and he's strong
and he's also by the way,
might've been oiled up.
Yeah.
How about that?
Mark Coleman told me
that he was backstage.
He saw Vandelay oiling up.
Vandalism,
a fight.
Fair.
Listen brother,
this is bad.
It's using.
He was Alex.
You can't do that.
I'd be shocked.
You'd be surprise.
Oh,
these fucking shots he hit no.
Carol with this was,
this is the roughest part of this fight
and Nogueira was another guy who was
known for his chin based on these fights.
He had the strongest Chin in MMA.
If you,
if you talked about
the best guards in MMA.
No.
Garrett is going to be up there.
Back then you'd be talking
about the best chins and MMA.
No,
isn't going to be back there and I'm like,
you're talking about the best chins now.
No.
Has been around,
you know,
th the sports so long that
his chin clearly isn't as
strong as it was back then
to a war.
I think he's going to do what
he's doing to watch for next guru.
Next know who is going to make millions
is the guru who could turn you from,
uh,
turn your Chin around and strengthen
your Chin and make yourself and turn you
into a guy.
There's gotta be some kind of technique,
not a group,
bro.
That's so fucking wizard.
He's going to come in on the Dragon.
Oh Man.
What if that happens?
What if there's something
that would have missed it?
I can make your Dick bigger and you give
up on fighting because Dick is so big.
You just check it out,
man.
When your Chin by or breathe
underwater underwater,
why would you fire taking these shots?
I'm going to bring your Chin back and
I'm gonna make your Dick Three inches
bigger.
Trust me.
Trust.
Well,
you know what's going to be really
interesting when they do come up with
genetically engineered human beings where
people have just unbelievably freakish
athletic ability.
You're not going to care as much about
like athletics and won't mean as much.
Like right now,
what it means is a representative
patient of your character,
of your will,
of your ability to do something
that most people won't do.
When you see a guy who was built,
you think two things.
One is the old folk would steroids,
but the other thing you think is like,
wow,
that guy has put in some
fucking work like this.
Even when a guy is on steroids,
if a guy is big,
the only way you get big is by putting
in the kind of work that most people are
not willing to do.
So when you see somebody,
yeah,
look at this man that was at
a Brazilian Electric Char.
Yeah,
it was beautiful.
So when you see someone
that they look at this,
he's trying to pass instantly
trying to pass that era.
That was a beautiful thing about Nogueira
his Jujitsu so smoothly that half a
side control immediately.
Look at this.
[inaudible]
her man so strong,
so strong.
It's such a good grasp.
Pausing Brian Jenny,
first time.
He's never satisfied.
He's never seen it,
but just the way he's been reacting.
There's no way he's ever seen.
He said MMA fan the way.
I'm like a fan of politics
and every now and then,
why'd you have to call me out?
Cause you know I'm like,
wow man.
Yeah,
any minute.
Well there was this guy,
Mark Fitch used to fight in the UFC.
Now he fights for the Superbowl of
fighting and just got armbars fought this
guy.
That guy's like a chimpanzee and arm bars.
Dude,
SPF.
That should be what a CBS comes out with.
Look at this.
It looks like he just woke up.
It doesn't have a scratch on his face.
Even in between rounds.
Calm as a cucumber.
The thing about these fights,
these pride fights in this widely known,
I mean,
you know,
you talk to guys like I had an incident
anyway on the podcast and ends and told
me like specifically said on his fucking
contract that they're not testing for
steroids specific.
Oh look at that bomb
Jesus crew on that one.
Right.
I think it would have been over to,
let's see,
just just those shots.
Don't you think as aggressive
as he was in his ground,
a pounds.
The same reason down the road when
he felt a guy like we're doomed.
Submitted.
Virgin was just way get caught.
People get caught.
Agree.
Whom?
Condom Verdugo tricked him.
He made it seem like you
went down and got hurt.
He pulled guard in a
different kind of way.
It's like,
oh,
why should I take them to get on top?
Boom.
If that third right hand
would it got through,
I think he would have been knocked.
You're still hitting him.
Boom,
boom.
Oh my God.
Those who was our right left,
right,
left,
right Jesus Christ.
That should be a gift right there.
That right.
Left,
right.
Holy Shit.
So Garrett could take it like nobody.
I feel like pride was back when baseball
didn't test and guys were hitting like
50 60 Homer's.
These fights,
they didn't test and he got shot last.
Each other in the face.
Exactly.
Plus the last time I
watched baseball on eep.
Oh,
they're all on EPA.
She crimes had his girl.
She loves him.
No good.
I heard don't guera
lives like a rock star.
That's what I heard you
made in Japan or Brazil.
He's a rockstar.
Yes.
Shit.
Good,
good.
I like it.
Enjoys life.
One other,
right.
He deserves that.
Fuck.
Anybody who's a warrior deserves that.
Know us.
No other.
Yeah,
I hear that Putin really likes
watching this,
but so let's pay attention to fade wars
physique because it will show some later
fade or
fights.
He's never been lean.
Well No,
no,
never lean.
But his bulk dropped substantially.
His amount of mass,
like his muscle power,
it drops shredder.
That would have been,
we should have been to a five
to a five the whole time.
Yeah.
He was two 30 and at least
20 pounds overweight,
like easily.
Could have been to 10 lean,
you know,
if like,
if Fado was like,
you know,
find a fighter,
a Russian guy,
like a poly bag routine off was shredded.
It fade or like got down
to that lean body mass.
He'd be two or three,
like without even cutting weight.
It's crazy,
but it's gut guys got a
little bit of a bad ass.
Was Carlson fucking Gracie man.
Who's your grandma's grandma?
When you look into the history
of what happened in Brazil,
Carlson Gracie was the man,
dude,
that was the round.
His whole pain.
They wouldn't know [inaudible].
They weren't on their boxing.
Look at all their guys and their
boxing Merola booster month.
They had some serious boxing,
so did the Noguera's.
I was like a throw down with their
feet and that was all Carlson Gracie.
How about fucking veto bro?
[inaudible] was the first guy to come
along see 12 the only Gracie's that had
really real hands or Carlson
Gracie's got that clan,
that Brazilian top team clan
that Carlson Gracie brought up.
That guy was the man.
That guy was the unsung
hero of the Gracies.
I'm shocked at how much bigger fade or
is physically like his muscles and his
old fights in awhile.
Much bigger.
Swole like 20 plus pounds of muscle.
Bigger.
Like if you look at him towards the end,
like when he fought Dan Henderson,
he's a shell of himself.
It makes me wonder like how the states,
that's true.
When you're hoists Gracie saying stuff
like you don't need to a trained boxing
or wrestling,
you just need you Jitsu like
all your needs is Jujitsu.
When you hear who I say stuff like that,
what do you think?
I think it's crazy you're saying
that to the other Gracie's though,
right?
He's not saying that for everything I
can on Roger Gracie for working on is
restructuring box.
Meanwhile Roger Crazy saying that now
as he's saying that slowly he's turning
into a decent strikers fucked up,
changed six screening dude,
how'd you Gracie is is turning into
[inaudible] if he just fucking turns that
striking training up the
coaches and he's got,
he's got the jazz athletic.
Is he saying he's saying that
now he's saying that today.
It's hard to listen to hoist today because
it makes me sad because I think you
know is just,
I dunno what's going on with him,
but all the shit that he said about you,
I put hoists in a new category.
Now I'm like,
okay,
he's that guy.
You know,
I don't know what's going on.
I don't know if it's
emotions or if it's anger,
but all the shit that he said about you
after you beat Heuler the second time.
I know you didn't win a
decision cause it was a draw.
You dominated him in that fight.
Let's just say that you dominated him in
that match a hundred percent everybody
knows it and you never said a bad thing
about the Gracies leading up to it.
You guys were very
respectful to each other,
you and heuler where before the match,
even after the match,
you gave it up to a boiler in the Gracies.
You always did.
You always have.
You always really cognizant about
it.
So when he got super upset about that,
I went,
okay,
this is like a non rational person.
There's a person who's
not thinking straight.
So when he starts talking about
like all you need is Jujitsu Mike.
Yeah.
Okay.
Until you fight someone
like Anthony Rumble,
fucking Johnson.
Good luck with all that.
Good luck when you Jujitsu,
when you get knocked into the fucking
next dimension with every Jabie throws.
Oh yeah,
good.
Try that out.
The reality,
the reality cold hard reality is
hoists Gracie in his prime UFC one.
Okay,
fights Anthony Rumble Johnson,
he gets put to sleep in 20 seconds.
That's a reality because
the game has changed.
It is a fucking whole new world and
when you deal with a guy like rumble
Johnson,
hate to keep bringing him up,
but he's a perfect example of a
wrestler who's a strong wrestler,
wicked takedown defense,
strong as shit and has
that God given power.
God Given Power with good coaching.
He's got Henri Hooft,
one of the best fucking
striking coaches in MMA period,
a real Dutch kickboxing striking coach
and he's teaching those fucking guys had
a throw combinations that are technical,
put strikes together,
be in the right position to land bombs
and he's dealing with this like super
athlete and Rumble Johnson.
If voice had a fight,
that guy,
he would have a different,
a difference of opinion.
He would realize like,
well,
you're different when you're dealing
with a completely different species of
human.
These are these super athletes of today.
They're just on a,
what would he do against Jon Jones?
Jujitsu's all your nude.
Okay,
good luck.
Good luck using your
Jujitsu on John Jones.
How do you explain that?
Like you don't,
you don't bother with someone says
the earth is 10,000 years old.
You get it.
Okay,
I got to go.
Here's the crazy thing is
not a fan on the planet.
Agrees with them.
Nobody agrees with them.
That one.
And he's the biggest
UFC legend of all time.
What was his Jujitsu?
What was the context of what I'm saying?
He says that he saying that Roger Gracie
was spending too much time working on
his striking.
That's why he's not successful.
He met him.
King Mo is a perfect example.
Why had to work on other shit?
King Mo put him to sleep.
You know why could really be King
Mo is a fucking elite wrestler.
Good luck trying to take king mowed down
Gould that he's ever been taken down if
he's cause he's Slippy.
Yeah.
King Moses
and one of the best
coaches I've ever seen.
There's,
you can coat some wrestling,
very technical,
you know,
he's kind of how he guy.
He's had a rough career man.
You know he's had some real ups and real
downs but I always like King Mo and I
always thought he's like,
he's gotten massive,
massive fucking potential.
He hit that electric chair again.
Eddie hit that electric chair again,
but king mo also has,
he has some serious knockout power man
and he knocked Haji route with him.
Bomb of a right hand cause the common
quietly looking around see the problem
with saying you only you Jitsu.
Well
what are you going to do with King Mo?
You gotta Take Tango
Down Wet slippery body.
Well it boys had this curriculum in this
system mastered of pulling guard and
then another system master to finishing
people off his back in this MMA way.
If he had those two
systems then I would say,
I see what it Sam,
because a guy like Paul Sas,
only guy in UFC history
who had the strategy,
every fight was the shoot,
make you sprawl and then pull
guard and finish you off his back.
He's the only fighter I
think and UFC history.
I could be wrong.
Dean Thomas was another guy like that.
He,
he strategically went out to throw some,
throw some strikes,
shoot,
make you sprawl,
pull guard and then fuck,
fuck you up off the back.
In that case,
if that's what voice is doing,
then I understand where he's coming from,
but I don't hear any of that from him.
I don't ever hear them talking about
different strategies to pull guard and the
best ways there should be.
There's at least five,
six,
seven different ways to strategically
pull guard and I'm not hearing Hawaii.
Think when it comes to hodge,
he's saying Hodges never going
to fight for a belt or whatever.
He has these crazy skills in Jujitsu.
Quit wasting time on working
on your striking wrestling.
Just win by Jitsu.
That's retarded.
You got to get your striking together.
If you're going to be an MMA fighter,
regardless,
I think he's saying focus on,
do you know well,
well Haji Gracie has one of
the best motherfuckers ever,
ever,
ever.
All right,
so when Omar would tell you what I,
what I would tell Joe Hodrick Gracie,
based on my experience and watching
fighters coming in the UFC and kind of,
I would say,
don't get frustrated.
The strikings going to take
about five or six years.
Don't get frustrated.
You got to get your fuck
and striking to get there.
You got to keep pushing.
You can't give up no
matter how many losses.
There's no way you're going to get to
the top with suspect striking and you're
on your feet and you're scared.
There's no way you keep
working on your striking.
You strive to be Jon Jones.
You strive to be Anderson Silva,
whether you reach them or not,
whatever.
At least you're trying.
You're trying to close the Tko James
McSweeney that he's turning into property.
Superdome.
Haji Gracie.
I would say keep working that striking.
Even if he loses his next two fights,
striking,
give them the right.
What's the chief's going?
Who Cares about your record?
No one knows anybody's record and
it's not like box room boxing.
It's all about the record.
MMA,
I'm a huge MMA fan.
I don't know anybody's record.
Emma is like,
how did you do your last couple of
fights and there's so much to learn.
You got to understand that people are co,
the fighters are constantly
in stages of development.
You're not done it when you
think you're done in development,
you are done in your career.
You've got to remain a student.
There's too much to learn.
You can't think even even John Jones,
the baddest motherfucker out there,
he's still got,
there's still a lot did
you get to to learn.
There's still what?
He's not Olympic caliber wrestling,
so you strive,
you keep learning new take downs off cage,
new takedowns,
different little takedowns off the cage
and and different setups off strikes.
It's endless.
You never stopped.
I was impressive.
Junior dos Santos is a clinch work
and he was much better than Steve Bay.
The zoot cheese in your
mouth while you're talking.
No,
it's a cracker.
It was more dramatic.
Oh,
her brother's a junior Terramark mark.
Listen,
did you hear about it?
How about Nate Diaz
versus a on Joe Sanchez?
Dos Anjos.
Holy Shit.
I think we not talked about dose
Angeles and not so much amazing button.
Then the other problem with that,
uh,
that he puts a lot of
weight on that front leg.
He comes in strong with that
jab cause he's got good reach,
but every time I've seen him I was like,
my God,
why isn't someone leg
kicking the shit out?
They're just not adapting to
the evolution of the game.
Right.
They're really not.
We're kind of kicks wrestling.
Exactly.
Bostik's almost disdainfully
like he's joking around with you.
Like he throws these like,
like his brother does.
They both do the same thing.
They'll throw at kicks when you're
nowhere near him because I like,
he'll like when you find across
and Nick Diaz kind kinda.
He just threw like the sloppy round house.
I tell you,
he goes,
oh,
we're throwing spent shit.
Now I tell all my fighters
coming through my gym.
I tell him all whether they
want to hear it or not.
I pull out my disclaimer.
I'm not a strike route or no shit.
This is just my opinion.
But if you're not striving to be a
striker like Conor McGregor or like John
Jones,
damn,
you're old school.
You've got to strike everything
that they're throwing.
Break it down.
Technically.
What is John Johnson?
He's still spinning elbows.
He's throwing sidekicks.
Spinning kicks the leg
telling me we'll kicks.
Don't work.
And you're watching Edson Barboza.
You're watching Vito Belfort who never
throw kicks before you saw him in his
career.
Add a dangerous weapon
like a spinning heel.
Crazy.
Everybody.
Alan Jobe on one of my fighters,
he doesn't throw a spinning heel,
heel kicks.
He doesn't do,
we'll kicks.
I constantly tell him,
dude,
add that shit.
You could do it.
You're very athletic.
It's going to take a little while,
maybe six months,
a year and a half,
two years.
Time flies.
We all know time flies.
But man,
before you know it,
you got to fucking wheel kicked it.
Your opponent has to train for and prepare
for and it throws them off balance.
You got to turn in psychic.
Look at that.
Like I'm Dee Diego Brandao.
What's his name?
And he said,
Brenda,
I was gather fought Conor McGregor.
Yeah,
those guys to steal everything.
You never know.
They're just like right here.
You don't know what the
fuck they're going to throw.
Spinning back fist.
We'll kick sidekick Conor McGregor
thrown couple of lyric kicks.
In my opinion,
that's the future right there.
A guy that can throw any kick,
any punch,
any spinning elbow,
all that shit.
You've got to strive.
Anybody listening out to strive for
that don't be one of those guys who just
sticks with boxing.
That's the other problem is guys get
into MMA and they get into MMA after a
lifetime of one style.
You know?
And sometimes it's very difficult for
them to incorporate other techniques.
Like say if you spend a
lifetime of just wrestling,
you know,
and you've never thrown
a kick in your life.
And then someone was saying,
you know,
you should throw head kicks.
Like why the fuck I could barely
touch my toes as long time.
That's a lot of these guys.
It's like you're dealing with
an elite athlete in one area.
But when it comes to like the
ability to learn how to kick,
you know,
I mean some work needs
to be done for sure.
Do you stretch?
Are you stretching now?
Yeah man.
He's stretching now.
Promise.
How much?
How much does that change?
Get obsessed with them up.
So that's what,
yeah,
but he didn't use a stretch.
A tall.
Did you use a stretch at all?
Crazy.
With my system come through my
system and when I tell people,
when people ask me,
I want to learn the rubber guard,
I wanted to do that flexible stuff.
What do I have to do?
All I tell him,
I tell everyone,
every guy,
just all you gotta do is be
able to get into the Bolus.
Basic Yoga positions of all time.
It is in a rubber guard position.
You're doing a lot of yoga.
I don't do yoga.
I do yoga stretches.
Right?
But what I'm saying is if you get,
if you can get into the most basic yoga
position of all time load is full lotus,
it's a position that you
have to learn in yoga.
I'll do some yoga and nobody has done
yoga for 10 years and not been able to get
into Lotus.
Eventually you get into
whether it's four years,
eight years,
six years.
It all depends on your work ethic.
That's it.
But what I tell people,
if you can get into that basic,
the most basic like Buddhas in the Lotus,
if you can get into that,
you can play all positions in grappling,
not just rubber guard,
very pliable.
And the real issue is there's a bunch
of studies that have been done on
flexibility and there are a lot of them,
I shouldn't say they're all,
but a lot of them are very flawed.
And I say this from a lifetime
of working out with people,
teaching people,
uh,
techniques,
especially kicking techniques,
seeing guys become more flexible and
knowing my own flexibility limits that I
became very flexible and I became
very flexible by going through pain.
So when they say like
someone is only able to,
you know,
get a certain amount of flexibility,
I say,
how do you know?
Did you,
do you know how much
effort they put into it?
How much time are they putting
in there to tell you what I did?
I put a fucking shit load of effort into
the reason why I could do a full splits
like this way and this way and
this way is because I didn't,
I couldn't do it when I first
started doing taekwondo.
So Bro,
black forced it.
He's got better.
We were at a meeting one
time and TV meeting and he
and we were just like these,
you know,
some people did a lot of TV and
he just grabbed both his ankles.
I'm like hey,
and put him straight up
and everybody's like,
well I didn't like,
but I don't remember why I did it.
I said,
yeah you got,
I had been doing martial
arts for a long time.
I'm really flexible.
Check this out.
Cause they were like,
Joe,
you do a lot of martial arts.
He goes,
yeah I do.
what are you doing?
Cause I don't know.
I just do it all.
And they asked me to show them something.
Right?
We want to see some crazy,
watch this.
I grabbed both my ankles and
I pulled them apart like this.
I can grab my ankles and I
think you want to grow in this.
And now that picture
is used for gate gifts.
And so that's a,
that's from a men's fitness.
But I mean,
you know,
when I did it was just for,
well congratulations out
of the way you've got that.
You've held onto it.
We'll still do that.
Yeah,
that was a war.
How long has that been?
You know,
you can kick like a mule.
I've seen he kicked,
I've never seen you do the legs.
Like you can't kick like
that unless you're flexible.
You don't have that.
This is like a witness
and a fluidity is part.
It's like when you see a guy
who really knows how to punch,
one of the things you realize is
they're not tense the whole way.
It's not like it's like there's a,
at the end of it there's like boom and
that's the same with kicking at the end
of it.
There's like a,
there's a witness and a crack.
It comes over and the the the,
the,
the amount of fluidity that you get and
you're kicking is directly proportionate
to the amount of effort you
put into your body type.
The bone structure is a lot of variables,
but a big one is flexibility.
That's a big one.
The more flexible you are,
the more you can fucking crack.
It's going to sound as good
a sound gay as fuck Brandon,
but man,
to have your good friend Joe Rogan
impresses world class fighters like GSP on
striking with power
that your friend,
if you this guy,
anybody he works with anybody
that holds pads with them.
They always trip
where everybody trips the fuck out,
right?
Every for years this has
been going on for 15 years.
Brendan,
this is nothing new to me.
We've,
this is going on forever.
This guy,
when you listen to
fucking powerful striking,
it's the fear factor guy.
How insane is that?
That is the craziest thing ever.
Nobody believes that shit.
How was it possible?
People warned me.
Dwayne told me to kick
guy before that thought.
Brian,
everyone told me what a Dwayne say.
Dwayne said this motherfucking kid,
regardless for Fido test,
whether it's a jab or the hook,
everything he throws,
it's,
it's all from the hip.
That's where all the power comes from.
That's what they say.
Common 30 he's got,
he's got talents with his hips.
I can only imagine how
you fucking laid pipe.
Just be like blah,
blah,
blah.
Pictures are just
fucking basic in the day.
Years ago,
[inaudible] Coleman fate or we're
watching Coleman fee might be the hardest
fucker ever.
Logan's been with this girl forever,
so it's been a long time,
but about 20 years ago for
sure will tell the story.
It's like sure it none of these stories.
Listen,
look,
look at Mark Coleman got fade
or down almost immediately.
Look at this.
Look at the difference here.
Look at the difference now.
Magic Coleman had monster Jujitsu
cause look at this fade or down.
Just beat up.
Show it.
Let's show it like right off the bat,
like,
look at this.
This is the beginning of the
elite.
He 39 39 years old,
39 he looks toward,
by the way,
these are all natural,
not natural,
a little natural.
None of them is not 100% natural.
No tanning beds.
No tanning beds at all.
I think this is Coleman.
Before he won the PR or did it,
was it after he won the
heavyweight Grand Prix?
I remember he won the
heavyweight grampy BlueCat.
Wow.
He takes him down.
That's a mother fucker.
That's strong as shit,
dude.
Mark Mad.
Everybody lifting weights.
Mark Coleman is the reason house.
Look at that.
Look.
Fade or tried to get up.
He's like negative.
Not Happening.
Do they do wizards in Russia?
Wizards in Siberia,
son,
but he's got us back here.
Joe Come on match and he's
got wrestling shoes on.
He's got his full back man.
Could you imagine if Mark Coleman had
a monster fucking guard and a monster
fucking remake control.
Yeah.
Look at this.
He's such an overlap or dude,
relax.
Look at just chuck the
and Mark Coleman's corner.
Look at this chocolate out
with no sleeves on his robe.
He never sleep.
Chuck Liddell deal in Japan that year.
Oh my God.
Look Randleman isn't that 10 or under
10 Kevin Randleman who's a WHO's a who
looks like a,
like if,
if Mike Tyson was in drag,
oops.
Oh look at this.
Boom,
boom.
Look at this.
Look at fader.
Don't kick yourself.
Have this drop.
Drop,
drop,
drop.
Well by this time Coleman was probably
already starting to get tired.
Why?
I don't understand metro one 17 no,
he was,
damn,
that's a serious guilty.
This is,
this is where it becomes a problem.
I forgot about this fight.
I don't know how it ends.
Don't tell apps a lot.
I don't know how damn feet or
used to grab the ropes a lot.
You ever see his fight with weapons?
Take tests to easy takedowns
his fight with who?
Matt Lynn.
Lynn,
Lynn Lynn and grabbing of the ropes,
he reversed the position
because he grabbed the ropes.
Lindland got a body lock on him,
was about to take them down.
Fade or fucking rope.
Grabbed,
flipped the switch and got on top of
him and then went up arm barring them.
Lucas Coleman just controlling
them on the ground.
Yeah.
Ah,
Shit.
Was He Tammy?
Look how fast that shit was.
You could do that.
Wow.
Easy.
Watch this again.
Keep wow.
Fucking close.
Look and look how relaxed
he is until he locks it up.
He's like,
is he really going to leave his Ah,
oh
God.
It's so beautiful that a thousand times.
That's all there.
The second time they
fought was in Las Vegas.
What pipe came here?
I was there.
I was there and he brought his kids.
Tries brother.
Ooh,
look at this shit.
Okay.
How glorious
that is.
Oh,
town Russian arm bar,
man.
He was so good.
He's so good at that shit.
He hid that shit on everybody.
Didn't he hit that shit on semi shelter?
He hit it on.
She'll every PSAP yet and
then now he never fought sal.
He avoided Sab.
That's right.
He was like,
no thank you.
That was three 75 we're missing.
Girl was like,
fuck that.
No gear for them.
Then they wanted to fight him and again,
he's like,
Nah man,
I had an hour conversation
with Bob sat one time about,
yeah,
hip hypnotism.
Like he was really into it.
He's really smart guy.
He is that dude his face.
I kept looking at his face.
It was so wide and so big.
He's just a,
he's just a different kind of smart guy.
Smart Guy.
I'm a nice guy and was really into it.
Really into I hypnotized like hypnotism
and just mind control and stuff were it,
they was giving me all
these books to read.
Um,
I want to watch the Fujita fight
cause I was a crazy cro cop.
One's good too.
Yes.
Trying to find food.
Geeta.
Tommy's got a lot of great fights,
man.
Gary Goodridge.
I forgot about that one.
You know the,
the other thing is when you look at
these guys' careers and he see how many
fighters that you forget how
many fights you forgot about.
Oh,
I know.
Yeah.
Mark Hunt.
Here's Cro cop.
What happened?
Oh yeah,
I remember that around him.
He beat him dumb on his fucking head.
Wow.
Moments later.
He did the same thing to him.
Come Maura Cyborg versus,
uh,
the hot chick.
Who,
what's her name?
Gina Corolla.
Do you wonder if that's
[inaudible] concert?
It sounds like a fucking Beatles.
Kind of like to see my crowd.
It's a bunch of chicks
screaming in the audience.
Gina Carano Cyborg.
That's one of the craziest
lights of all cheering for Gina.
Gina said I was doing movies.
Fucking,
it was like a Brittany Spears concert.
Hmm.
There's never been a
fight like that before.
Where did just chicks.
Oh,
this is pride bad to the bone,
handsome.
All Morocco was fighting
somebody else back then.
Boy,
he looked fucking different.
He looked like street fighter Bolus.
We're done.
It's really a shame that bus
route and never fought in pride.
It would have been really interesting
to see him fight in pride.
Boss was a fucking murderer.
Do like,
whew.
I mean,
was watching her real athlete first
real striker in MMA when he fought in,
um,
pancreas.
He got seat,
he threw kicks the guys like,
what the fuck is this?
I watched him hit a bad
kick a bag with his shin.
It was the craziest
thing I've ever started.
It sounded like a gun was going off.
You Never Seen Pedro his,
oh,
kick her back.
No.
Pedro his own throw some life
changing kicks on the bag.
His coach said he won't,
he won't hold myths warm.
What
he said he did it once with
the hips are about this wide.
They're there.
They're literally about a quarter mile.
He's got God damn tree
trunks for legs too.
But the thing about Pedro,
his,
oh his man,
he would like,
he had really good technique to
Real Holland style kickboxing,
but he would hit guys with one leg kick
and you would see them go like what?
Really?
Because guys were used to eating
a certain amount of leg kicks.
You know,
like guys were hit anybody kicked legs
the way Ernesto hoost does though I was
really good.
Nesto was a technician,
but Ernesto hoost didn't have the
kind of power that his overhead,
his jab,
right kick to the body and
freakish power when his,
oh,
fought Rico Rodriguez in um,
in the UFC,
he hit Rico with one leg
kick like early in the fight.
Just,
and you could see the look on
Rico's facing like fuck all this.
And Rico just completely
adjusted and decided to survive.
Oh,
I key literally decided to survive from
like the opening moments of that fight
he got.
It'll change your career
so ruined your whole,
it'll,
they'll just change everything.
Well,
he fucked up.
Randleman so bad.
Random.
His legs are still damaged to this day.
He's go,
yeah,
he's got crazy all over his leg.
He's got,
who'd you say fade or?
No,
Randy couture.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Crazy dense Aly and I'm weird vein.
God,
he broke their veins open.
The veins recuperate,
but they,
they form new channels.
So like all over,
you're like,
he has,
he's gnarly bubbling veins all over
his leg where his oak kicked him.
Fuck that all over his leg.
I'm sick in the car.
I was going to get an MMA.
I'm gonna stick to comedy.
I think maybe he honest with me,
don't play with me.
See this is fade or versus fruit.
Geeta.
And this is like a fight
where he got in the worst,
the worst fatal.
It looks at these before
and after in a body contest.
This looks like it before.
Yes,
he's got,
he's got a bad stomach,
but look at this.
Watch this.
He knows how to throw those hammers.
Oh Dude.
He also knows how to surprise you.
I mean metal,
that soccer ticklish,
big soccer kicks for big and properly,
right?
Totally different experience,
man.
Yeah,
not a good thing.
And you could need of the head right
when something's on the hasp knees.
That's,
that's devastating.
I'm surprised they don't have that.
And you have to say that
that changed with cages.
It's different.
Why is that the cage?
Because you could trap a guy up,
stomp them soccer,
kick him.
Right.
The thing about the ropes as you can slide
around underneath it and avoid stuff,
right.
It's good in that respect.
There's probably a better solution.
Someone hasn't figured out yet.
I don't know what it is,
but here's a,
here's where it gets rocked like fate or
comes in on Fujita and Fujita throws a
fucking hammer his way and Fujita
look at the sides of his head.
He was a big dude.
He's all fucked up too.
Now man.
Alistair Overeem changed his life.
Oh,
that knee Fujita looks like he's
moving like an old man right there,
I think.
I mean he's just stiff legged.
Put a black suit on him
and he's the odd job.
He's a bad guy from James Bond.
The hit blesses.
Oh snap dude.
Rubber legs.
He's all over the place.
That mother fucker knows
how to survive though.
Yes.
It's an amazing that he
couldn't for Cheetah,
couldn't get them off him with grief.
Believable,
greasy arms is over.
Hook was so strong.
Then when he got hit,
he just took off.
He was able to hold on.
There's the ref cam right there.
Wow.
He just took a bad,
the ref cam is pretty bad ass Christ and
if they had a ref cam today it would be
high def.
So it'd be even more bad ass.
That'd be sweet.
Yeah.
They probably should have.
When I see that it's so rough.
Could say I didn't see the IPOS pitch.
How can we can see the eye poked
through the fucking roof cam you lazy.
Fuck yes,
my head was looking that way.
But my eyes were looking that way.
Your honor.
One of them ring car
girls done distracted me.
Yeah,
you could bring that.
It's just they got a new
Brazilian ring card girl.
The judge like you got to
understand because the pictures,
what's going on.
A fitter is going to be a
little still a bunched up here.
Yeah,
he's back up to his feet while
he's probably slowly recovering.
Cheetah almost throws him man.
He posted on his arm.
That's fucking dangerous shit here.
This shit right here.
Blip,
blip,
blip and it turns it around.
Yeah.
Well striking those.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Standing.
Standing right there.
Right there.
Kick to the body.
Fucking well.
I think he knows cause she
does a lot slower than he is.
He doesn't know that
both you guys quiet down for a second.
Jab Hook.
It's fake blood too.
Huh?
Thank you.
Zoomed in all too big.
Look at this kick.
Boom.
Oh fucking him up with strikes and then
closes out with a rear naked choke.
Look at that shit.
It's choking the shit.
That's how you fight man.
Having the ability to do
everything is so important.
Having the ability to do everything,
get them to,
he got rocked in that fight.
Fuck yeah,
you did.
And look at him.
Walk around like nothing happened.
Nothing happened.
A bunch of homos naked men hitting
his back or branches tough.
Oh No.
He just got choked on.
Well that's,
that's the least of is if
you watch his Overeem fight.
Where did he fight over him?
His dream was a dream.
It was dreamy.
Eats a need.
It like concaves is fricking,
he was out for half an hour.
No,
stop it.
It's tough to watch,
man.
Yeah.
They said it was one of the
worst knock outs ever for a half.
It sounded like a shotgun.
Oh yeah.
That's horrible.
Yeah,
man.
Well,
how's he doing now?
Fantastic,
man.
No,
he's writing books and shit.
Still
Riding High.
Curing cancer and shit.
It's so cool.
I said no one ever.
Come on,
man.
Who Do you,
uh,
do you guys want to do?
Doing now?
Who Do you want to see some early,
it was Anderson a ever fight in pride.
Yeah,
he fought in pride.
Uh,
Anderson,
some of those.
Nick Diaz file two.
We fought Alex de bling,
the Brazilian Kyla.
Remember that tone and room tone up
with that beautiful flying scissors to a
heel hook.
Yeah,
I'm watched.
I'm watching Nick Diaz.
Let's watch some fucking classic Vandelay.
Oh,
let's watch vendorlink cro cop
because it was Vandelay cro cop too,
especially was a real,
it was a real education in what happens
when an elite striker gets good at
takedown defense.
You know what,
what happened?
There's something that happens to
these guys when they get really good at
takedown defense where they start,
they start figuring it all out and then
they get loose on their feet and then
you see the gap between
them and an other people.
You know what?
Uh,
which one did,
did Vandelay fight?
I have to start taking my
take down defense and my deep,
I take down defense a lot more seriously.
That happened.
Shut the fuck up.
What would I say?
Shut the fuck.
This is the big one.
This is when,
uh,
for whatever reason Vandelay decided that
he was going to go up to heavyweight.
Is there going to be a hangover?
Five
has been been a forum
Mirko favorite fighter of all time.
Really?
No,
Garrett.
Number two.
Wow.
How weird is it?
I fuck both of them.
What fucking world do we live in?
They have Marco was only 32 back then.
Some Latin kind of crossover stuff like
Russia and kind of where we go look at
this shit boy.
Dude.
How scary was the natural hair?
Yeah,
but this is Vandelay as a heavyweight.
He was two 18 here.
Cro.
Cop was actually two 14 he can throw,
but this is cro cop at its best.
Cops in the legs.
This is cro.
Cop had his best.
This is when he was sponsored by Purina.
No,
that's the flag.
Of course.
Don't be rude.
Boom.
Look at Oh,
can kick to the body.
Jesus Christ.
That shit was on.
He was so gangster.
He was so much better before the tattoo.
Oh my God.
Vandelay yeah,
no,
I'm talking about Cro.
Cop.
Dude,
look at this hammer fist.
He was just,
Oh my God.
He was just fucking
Vandelay up in this fight.
So strong.
He was so good back then.
He would just that kick to the
body and the opening round.
I could watch that all day long.
That shit was ridiculous for sure.
The greatest left kicker ever.
Ever.
How much different is wonderland look now?
Driving a different face
lift or whatever he did?
Well,
yeah,
it is a piece of rib taken
out to reconstruct his nose
and he had his nose made
extra large so he'd get more air in it.
You know what have they got a more pussy.
Nice.
I don't think it did.
He's always agree with it,
but watch this shit man.
This is rough because he
was already beaten up.
He was already beating out.
Boom,
straight left.
Mirko was so goddamn laser
beam accurate back then too.
He's just fucking going off on Vandelay.
There's also the first fight,
which is maybe the scariest
fucking stare down ever.
Ever.
Hands down when Vandelay and cro cop was
standing vandelays doing all his normal
like intimidation shit and
cro cop's looking at him like,
I've killed motherfuckers with a knife.
You know,
he's got like that face.
Yeah.
That was the only time
Vander Lee has ever been out.
Uh,
scared out.
Stare down,
out,
stare down.
Yeah.
It was the only time.
Usually we see cro go still
finding he's fighting.
I think he,
she soon bully.
Fond dream.
Yaks or in now she did well he,
he won a k one,
right?
The heavyweight one.
A version of a Grand Prix.
Yeah.
Like a year ago.
Look at Vandalia
knows how to curve.
It was mashed.
There's a lot of guys like that,
so they get that sense that,
that smash part of the middle of the nose.
Oh,
he wants to fight.
Look in his eyes.
The doctor's going to stop it.
That's all fake.
They very rarely kind of dots in Japan for
giving him a break
to let them recharge.
Make the fight better.
Yup.
So they create some drama.
They make it look great.
They might stop it.
Oh,
WWF.
Not sure.
They would never stop any,
there's not,
there's not enough blood
to even consider it.
The problem is while they're doing this,
they're given cro cop a break too.
And that fucking dude
was so goddamn explosive.
Nope.
He's not even yoked.
Uh,
he was only two 14 back then,
man.
I mean,
he's yoked,
but it's a different kind of yoked.
He carries around a lot of weight now.
It looks very different
than he looked right now.
Tell him I'll go up to 50 to 40 somewhere.
Yeah.
What think you ways to 35 you said he
was the strongest guy you ever tied up
with,
right?
Hands down.
Wow.
Not even close.
Jesus this,
they started him on the ground again.
I liked that.
Vandelay throwing some
hammers from his back here.
Hello.
God
Damn.
I just want to see it when it gets to
the feet and I don't want to hear the
commentary
trying for arm bars and shit.
Nobody's even talking.
Saw me carrying this podcast
once.
It's like Dennis,
I haven't seen this first
time calendar ever seen it,
so he's just super,
totally,
I knew it.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
What does that you're,
I wanted the,
uh,
this is amazing.
It's a bar talking to the microphone.
Probar yeah.
Don't want to put you
on the mic or anything.
But this bars,
I've been looking at it for two hours.
Go on.
It's delicious and look good.
Great.
There are a couple though with the mic,
right?
Yeah.
Was on it.
We should probably break
down too bad for the Mike.
How about that?
When I went hunting Nazi bro,
break out the pickles right now.
I just feel good and everybody else eat
a pickle and give me one this to stand
up so I could see the end.
Well we want pickles so you can,
you want it to stand up and
I won't fucking pickles.
I've been here for six hours.
We'll get a fucking pickle.
Right?
And I haven't been here for six
hours and you were 40 months,
whatever.
I brought wine and and I brought Jesus
gets him to eat after this and you guys
want to get some dinner?
Too late.
I'm sorry I can't eat that thing.
Come on.
I'm sorry.
I have rules,
rules,
Diet.
I just,
I'm sorry.
There's some things I won't do.
I want to be pushed that
far right here it goes.
Here it goes.
I should look at this.
Eddie back up to the feet.
Sweat.
Here comes,
there's not a Krispy Kreme from miles
away and you don't want to settle for
less.
You know what he the game,
a yellow car fucked up back then.
Two men and they would give dude's yellow.
What does that mean in activities?
God,
what's that?
10% 10% baby.
Here it goes though like this.
Get randomly slapped,
kicked out of his right eye.
Wash this look up.
Good Cro.
Cop's slides too.
Good.
Good movement.
Boom to the bodies.
Hooks for days out of wonder.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
he never threw it straight.
Parts of her.
Very rarely.
Well you had very narrow
shoulders for a big muscular guy.
Here comics comes here she comes.
Oh my God who just setting them up.
I got butterflies.
I've seen it a hundred times.
He's just setting them up though,
man.
Oh yeah.
You can never give cro cop setup time.
You cannot do it
manually tagged him.
But look,
Cro,
cop back forth,
cop still out of Chin back then,
man.
He could take it back then.
Oh my Lord.
The straight laugh to the
face and the hair comes,
oh good Lord.
I refer stop.
Oh my God,
look at that stuff.
Fucken Gash on the side of
his head with a Shin Land.
It's horrifying.
Yeah.
Well he was one of those dudes,
man that's caught me with that kick
the way he moved and that's awful.
So different.
He wasn't no world.
Oh God.
Oh Christ.
That's so bad.
He moved so different back.
He looks dead dude.
By the time he got into the
UFC and you kind of wonder,
you know,
because of the,
what they did in pride as far as
like the drug testing and shit.
You gotta wonder what these guys
were and weren't on back then.
And then you get off of it and there's
this like this period where your body's
just not the same.
Right?
Like a perfect example that
I always use is Roy Jones Jr.
When Roy Jones jr fought John Ruiz,
he got up to like 199 pounds,
like ripped,
shredded.
And then he got to go all the way down
to one 75 when he fought Antonio Tarver
after that and he looked like dog.
She just,
when he got knocked out,
right Tarver was the first guy to stop
him and Tara didn't just knock them out.
He changed his career,
changed everything.
Then after that he fucked Glen Johnson.
Glen Johnson knocked him out bad.
Well,
they said that,
that,
that he was so gifted physically and so
fast that he actually did he that when
he lost a step because he didn't really
have to work on fundamentals the way
somebody who wasn't that fast fasted.
Once he lost his step,
he was getting knocked out by
guys who were really educated.
It was so fun to watch,
man.
Oh,
he's the best.
My favorite ever.
I hate her.
Not that Mayweather pack yell.
Foot's going to happen.
Huh?
Is it?
That's what they're saying.
Whether you call them out,
call them out and then pack.
I was like,
cool.
Money's not an issue.
I don't care about the money.
Let's just make it out because
money was what was holding it up.
That's going to be the
biggest money making papers
they've done about five years
ago.
Yeah.
But this is a good time for it.
It would have been better five years ago,
but it's still really good.
So what he did to,
to Algeria,
I mean there's just took his whole game.
Well Algeria not on his level.
I mean I'll do it really do I really know
that before the fight when you listen
to people,
they weren't saying that he was going
to get out class that everyone knew was
too big of a jump for Algeria though.
I didn't hear that.
I heard,
think about first off,
personal drunk guys,
vertical hunter,
uh,
Bradley,
Tim Bradley and they were talking and
they were very respectful of Algeria.
Like a plus 1200 underdog.
No one gave him a shot like Vegas.
Like he's exactly how
you would think of a guy.
Lived with his parents,
which he does.
He does.
Yeah.
He lives with his parents in the basement,
but it doesn't have,
he has money now.
I mean he beat providing the cough.
I know he made some money and
decide he's going to keep us
200,000 miles.
I like him even more.
He just said it likes to
be around his family plot.
Floyd Mayweather.
Don't be a box in a humbug.
Give the fans the fight they want.
They have waited long enough.
Wow.
Dang son.
I like the dot right
before Floyd Mayweather.
Let everybody know.
We'll put the little
period before for Amanda,
so it's not just in his APP mentions.
Oh,
so if you go dot.
I just learned that it's kind of a lame,
that call out.
Don't be a humbug.
Cute.
That's what he is.
He's a nice guy.
His yes.
That fucks people up.
Yeah.
He's an interesting guy.
They did a thing on skeleton.
These facial hair
feel
Bieber haircut with a gang gets Khan
who stops.
They did a analysis of like his
skeleton apparently has a very,
very large wrists,
big bones.
They're talking about like the d.
One of the reasons why he's been able to
carry his punching power up through the
ranks and why he's so successful
and knocking guys out and they,
they,
there's a direct correlation between
the size of certain parts of your bones,
particularly like wrist size,
like wrist size is like,
his cats are huge,
huge lessons.
Manny Pacquiao,
his speed,
but it's speed.
It's just so awkward.
He's just a beast.
And just to be Nice Guy Dick,
he thinks so for a little guy,
Dick size,
size had effected your power.
What have they learned that
and they tested him and I no,
just carry a laugh in there.
And you kind of short,
I'm not dumb.
No serious question or serious question.
Brendan,
how many inches are you
serious?
How should we have a voice dropped
and he got whispery about it.
Serious question.
Brendan.
How many inches are I like shit like that.
Me Too.
I like shit.
All I want to know is about it.
I care about.
It's got to be honest.
Okay,
this could get you more pussy.
I'm all set,
man.
I can't take it anymore.
No,
I'm just kidding.
Oh,
to 13 inches.
Eddie.
Thank you for asking.
That's a very,
that's bigger than Lexington style.
I'm just kidding.
Dot.
I forgot.
Roy Nelson fought cro cop.
How'd he do it?
Right after Roy.
Roy took his back and smashed him.
No oil be cro.
Cop.
Yeah.
Now's the Cro.
Cro.
Cop had them wobbled though.
Did you remember that Cro
cop had run the ropes?
They kicked him or something
straight left with or what was,
it landed a nasty body shot on him too,
but yeah,
Cro,
cop got him down.
Tk Odom?
Yeah.
Oh,
you mean a Roy got him down.
Yeah.
Um,
I want to see Roy versus Nogueira.
Oh really?
Yeah,
just to see like office at the end.
What?
The giant right hand.
Yeah.
I can't believe you want to watch that.
You don't want to watch that.
That's tough to watch,
man.
It's like,
what's like no gears fricking oh,
like this still,
it just gets
okay.
Annihilated.
It's basically the end
of a freaking legend.
I know.
Yeah.
Made me sad.
Definitely south stiff.
MMM.
It is what it is.
Cost.
What about the Bob Sapp days.
Okay.
Sap Nogueira Carlos Newton.
Palae how about,
I'm sure we already saw Bob Sapp.
Nogueira we've done that
on the podcast before.
I think people will go.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
How about Bob Sapp Cro cop?
Was that his kickboxing?
Yes.
Jose Conseco Hoe man choice.
Oh No,
you need to sleep more.
How bad?
How bad my car,
I remember Mark Current,
his body captain America right there.
Right.
He had the craziest boats,
Planet Mark Carr.
Remember him?
I heard mark likes the way the Dick Taste.
Wow.
What's your price?
There was a rumor.
Huh?
What's your price from our car?
I do 100,000 if anybody's
ever watched that documentary.
Exactly what I was talking.
You haven't watched that documentary.
The smashing machine.
Great documentary.
I mean crazy documentary
cause they followed Mark Hunt
who at the time Mark Carr
rather mark her at the time was a world
class mixed martial arts fighters,
trashy guys,
and had this unbelievable body and they
caught him in the middle of this like
drug spiral.
Downward spiral.
Right.
We know that when they were making it,
they had no idea they got
there with the camera.
He fell apart.
The crazy thing about Margaret is he told
me this is the pain because when Mark
Coleman was rising in the UFC and there
was a couple of the wrestlers,
there's no Kara mops.
Her said that guys were always telling me,
look dude,
you should do the UFC.
You got to do it.
You'd kill these guys.
And Mark Her said he did not
have any interest in fighting.
He kept saying,
those guys are animals.
I don't have that animal instinct.
I mean,
if people kept telling me,
dude,
it'll be so easy.
You look at Mark Coleman,
he's a star,
he's making all this money.
He's taken people down.
You could do this.
And then they twisted his arm.
He signed a deal with the UFC and
then backed out of it cause he,
he just was not confident.
And then he decided,
damn,
maybe all he got off an offer in
Brazil to do an eight man tournament.
And he said,
okay,
I'll do this,
uh,
this low key tournament in Brazil.
See how I do and then now we'll evaluate.
After that,
he went down to Brazil.
He was scared shitless.
Mark Kerr was scared shitless,
throwing up in the bathroom,
had diarrhea.
This is what he was telling me.
He was
freaked out.
He went out there,
one the eight man tournament,
got to it was a bare knuckle,
so he got the staph
infection all up his arms.
So he was in Brazil.
He won this thing,
he won this tournament.
He beat Fabio's,
your shell and the final and there was
no gloves and he got the staff up his
arm.
He almost died in the hospital in Brazil.
It was terrible.
He was supposed to win $20,000
a promoter of the show said,
Eh,
it is Brazilian tax.
You're getting 11,000 or whatever.
So he got fucked with the money.
He would had a nightmare
experience in the hospital.
When he finally got home,
he said,
I'll never do this again.
But he started reading
stuff on the Internet about,
they started calling him
the smashing machine and,
and in Brazil,
a mucky Nadia fucking
a smushy or whatever,
and all of a sudden he thought,
wait a minute.
Hmm,
maybe I will do this again.
And then that is funny.
Yeah.
If you want to freak out.
He wrestled at one 88 and then he
fought to 60 look at the size of,
yeah,
that's crazy.
I mean,
the size of Bob.
Forget about anybody else.
Anybody that's ever lived,
never forget about anybody
when you talking to size.
So forget about anybody that ever lived.
Look at there's no Garrett's
still tries to take them down.
Oh fuck this world up for five years.
Right.
That really jacked it up.
Powerball Paul Orndorff.
Mr. Wonderful driver pile driving first
pot first strong is seeing the first
minute of a fight.
Unbelievably the strongest
fighter ever for first minute.
Yeah.
He's unbelievably strong.
Him a car when he was three,
he's bigger than car window.
He's 375 pounds with a
gift that no one can.
I mean that's,
he's pile driving people and
he's on every drug known to man.
I mean he's allowed to
take whatever he wants.
I mean he's just,
he was so much bigger.
He was a hundred pounds.
So that's a natural.
Some guys are that Beck.
Yeah,
totally.
Three 75 would abs is totally normal.
We see it all the Tate
Tate was in that movie,
the longest yard with him and a tape.
Tate was like,
the dude carries around
doctor's bag everywhere he goes.
He's just got,
he's just got supplies like you.
You
can hear it.
He was terrified to fight.
I'm sure they said he'd be in the
back like just a super nice guy.
Super Nice Guy.
Like a smart,
smart.
Ivan salivary is a friend of mine and
he's really close with Bob Sapp and he's
just like the sweetest,
nicest guy ever who just
found a way to make cash.
I heard he made a killing
and ships in Japan.
Yeah.
But then it all went away,
man.
It all went away in a big way.
Like he,
when he,
when he backed out of k one,
you know,
that whole deal,
like they were,
they the Yakuza apparently allegedly,
uh,
due to,
you know,
unforeseen circumstances did not
have the contract ready for him.
And they were trying to get them
to fight without a contract.
He was like,
fuck you.
So he backed out of the,
the main event and like
they don't play that shit.
Don't play that shit.
Like he was worried about his life.
Like,
look at the size of him here.
Good Lord.
No Garris still trying for that takedown.
And that gets probably all jacked up.
Yeah.
But if he was who some
are Paul Harvest it,
you know,
he could have at least grabbed a hold of
like,
you know what,
I'm not going to go through them.
I got to pull guard,
I got to beat him off my back.
And that's what he ends up doing in this,
he sweeps someone that arm bar and his
neck is probably already injured pretty
bad.
So at some point he made the decision,
I can't take this motherfucker
down if I keep trying.
It's,
it's not gonna work.
I gotta pull God,
I got to meet him off my back and
he's got to do old school hoists.
Gracie cook him then and
he's prepared for what?
He has confidence and he was like,
I can beat him off my back
because in the gym all day
tire mount.
Yeah,
but is he beating someone that's big.
I mean cause even know anybody that I peg.
No,
that's the thing about SAP.
You don't even know.
You don't know anybody that big.
Who are you going to get to train
fucking difference in the size of them.
I mean that's,
that's Goddamn Komiko he
hates getting hit though,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
He doesn't like to see that.
When he got hit and he hated it,
it'd be that half ass.
I know.
Welterweight to kick harder than that.
Maurice was training him though.
You know Maury Maury Sabbath,
right?
Yeah.
Maurice had them,
you know,
at least competent and Barnett,
right?
Yep.
Josh was in his corner for this.
Yeah.
I mean he's a Seattle guy.
That's right.
Boom.
I started getting tired and this fight,
it's crazy how far everything
has come since 2004
I'll never forget watching this fight,
watching the slide going fucking nuts.
All I was thinking about in
the beginning was he's too big.
He's not going to win.
He's just too big.
There's no way he can do this.
He's too big.
Switch.
Ooh.
Oh Shit.
That was Bob as a child.
Too late though for this round,
but when he got Bob inside,
controller's working,
trying for a Kimora on a 375 pound man.
That's Hilarious,
dude.
Bob Sat up him in his guard.
I don't know his neck looks fine.
No,
it's not filed.
Shut the fuck up.
380 pound dude slammed
you on your neighbor,
your,
your weight,
his weight on your neck.
Believe me,
you've got an interview.
Said he [inaudible] give them a chance.
What's that?
Okay,
that's fine.
The speed or wouldn't find them just,
I worked at lower body Mosley allows
your neck problems come from your lower
body,
your hip area,
your toes,
your,
your next hurt because your,
the hips are super tight.
It's one of those guys guys.
You think you'd have some magical secrets?
Kurt's because your ass is a swear to God.
I got a massage and calls with the guy
wanting to put his fingers up my hands
and you let it out.
I swear to God,
he told me that there's
a nerve center there.
The releases,
all the muscles.
I went,
I know.
That's cool bro.
Me,
I can't hurt anybody's feelings.
I was going,
I know,
but it's cool.
It's cool.
But you know what I think I'm going to,
I'm going to have to
trying to finger your ass.
Yup.
Sorry broke.
Cause I'm,
I'm,
I'm good with it.
I just need to this part,
this car [inaudible] Bro.
It's in your hips.
Told you that.
Huh?
Why don't you talk about that on stage?
It's
a double fingers up.
My write up my ass like,
no,
he gave me a massage.
You saying he was a mysterious and then
I sat and I was my back really hurt in
college.
I had a bad back,
so my lower back and he goes,
he goes,
sure.
So he's massaging me and he's touching.
Everybody were,
but my feet on my is weird.
My feet,
I mean my,
my back,
where's he saw my feet,
my legs.
Then he starts talking about my ass.
And then he goes,
your whole lot of tension here.
And I'm like,
okay,
this feels good though.
He's like a massage on my glutes.
And then he goes,
he goes,
I swear to God.
He goes,
so now this is going to be weird.
Maybe in the beginning
you have a nerve center,
you have a nerve center
right next to your prostate.
And he goes to,
what I do is I'm going
to get right up here.
And he goes,
let's begin.
So how are they gonna run up there
with my fingers and I'm in a massage,
the area.
And what's going to happen is
you're going to let go completely,
but you got to really let go.
Start letting go now.
And I go,
I was the that w what do you mean?
He goes,
I'm going to put it,
I'm going to put it.
I'm going to have to go in your anus.
And I go,
no,
no.
I to know.
And it's okay because for me,
I'm,
I'm more tight here.
I go,
oh.
So I'm not used to that.
So that's not something
I'm not used to.
Yup.
So then I find out,
then I find out that my buddy who is
from Jordan and I really macho dude,
macho dude,
he was Jordan and from Jordan and Germany,
good looking guy,
always combed his hair with a brush and
wore tight jeans and pulled his balls
and cocked to one side.
And he was very happy
with the character I do.
I take this woman to my bed I
made that was based on this guy,
and I don't want to say his name,
but he,
he,
um,
I found out that uh,
he up fingered,
fingered and then he let
the do blow and he's like,
oh man.
Well we were all like this.
We were like,
yeah,
but he's from Jordan and
it's probably kind of macho.
Hello
guys.
Not from America.
Maybe it's like a cultural thing.
Wait a minute,
you lift that was talking about it again.
He let her go a finger
your ass and then blow you.
That is a gay,
I would imagine.
That's what I would say.
No experiment.
Not to be,
but I was in college and I
saw him have sex with a girl.
I had sex in a room where
you know you're younger,
you're like,
oh,
we can't afford a hotel room.
We got to share one.
I'm having sex.
He's having sex with a girl,
do it.
He bangs girls as well.
Girls at guys.
Well,
well in hard and he was working at peace.
I know dudes go both ways,
but he left a guy blowing shit.
Put his fingers were right up in,
but this is a guy who hasn't
done that in other places.
Just did it this one time or what's that?
Look guys,
I don't know man.
We didn't really talk about it after that.
We were like,
that's not the first time was the one.
I was like,
you know what man,
we'll give him a pass on the control.
Did you find out that he
got blown up by the guy?
He,
the guy who did it told my buddy,
Dan,
very,
very confidentially,
because Dan,
my buddy was Dan and I also
got fingered in the bucket.
Dan was a little guy and he goes,
she used to hang out with substrate,
fucking tricky gay guys university.
And Dan goes,
so dang.
So,
so check it out like what?
He goes there,
a lot of people didn't hear in your
myths that have had things with guys.
I was like,
like,
who?
And he goes,
well don't tell him back,
told you this,
but blah blah blah.
And I was like,
Oh man,
there it is.
But he was so macho,
but you hold on,
sorry,
go
back it up.
So,
um,
I remember these stories.
You,
you forget stories and he got a
guy who tried to finger your ass,
hold this other God,
this is where the fingers
ass and blow them.
But that guy never admitted
it to anybody else.
No Way.
So how do you know it's even true?
The Guy,
he's a trickster.
You said the guy wasn't even the way
he did it because he only told my other
friend who was gay and
was getting made him say,
not tell anybody because he's lying.
It could easily be because he's lying
and he's got a fantasy of blowing your
heart ass.
Jordanian friend may be her story up
and then you had big tells you like it's
look,
guy blows everybody good.
Let him blow.
Yeah.
But it was next thing you know,
the guy who was a big
secret in mice in my house,
he didn't want the Gig.
I didn't want anybody to know he cause
you probably thought your friend would
kill him.
The Jordanian friend.
I mean,
he's a Middle Eastern guy.
It's very likely is it must Zeus or not?
Yeah,
no,
he weak bro.
Crew was pretty,
I used to tell a bit about bisexuals
that I don't think they really exist.
I think there's gay dudes and
then there's really gullible,
straight dudes who get talked
into blow and crafty gay dude,
this guy is like making my act real.
That's probably true.
That's what a bisexual is.
There's guys who just crafty as fuck.
My friend Jimmy used to say,
they're just greedy.
That's what he used to say.
Bisexual is their fucking greedy.
He goes,
if you just create each one,
everything,
eh.
Gimme gimme
gimme gimme pick a team.
He just liked attractive people.
Well,
does guy,
um,
do you still Facebook?
No.
Over how did you end up
sparring session on the massage?
They just gave me,
he finished it up and they said,
well,
he goes,
he goes back.
He goes,
he goes,
I messed it up.
Well,
we did it for awhile,
but he charged them what?
He goes,
he goes,
it's something you have to work
up to and it's something that I,
I think I can read almost
had you for a little bit.
We were like,
yeah,
maybe I,
I was like,
that would be weird.
How would I do that?
Wait,
I'm going to tell you something else.
I'm making this up now that I remember it.
I blocked some of it actually
he did massage my tank.
[inaudible] I swear to God he massage
that area because he told me that area is
where a lot of tension and I was like,
this is awful.
I remember my toes kept pointing.
I don't know.
I was like,
Oh,
oh,
oh God.
I feel bad with confrontation.
I didn't want to be employed
so I just thought it happen.
Yeah.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm good man.
That's cool.
My lower back,
I get pointed in my lower back
muscles that were over here.
Jokes come from probably
that's all I do on your tape.
You got to do besides your team.
She have been picked up.
I haven't had a bad back problems
since you've been picked up for cross.
He got arrested for prostitution.
When
I don't eat crackers,
the crackers.
I was um,
this is great.
I just felt the other day,
but everybody thinks that it was fighting,
so I was like,
people like you got arrested?
Yeah,
why?
I was fighting.
I have a whole story about it.
Prostitution up.
Well,
no it wasn't,
but that wasn't,
I was not trying to pick up prostitutes.
I'm see the story that you
tell me what he was doing it,
I have paid for sex.
Now.
Anyone who knows me knows
that and I believe in it.
I just haven't done it.
I believe it,
believe in it.
I think it really does exist.
It's not Santa Claus.
That's true.
And,
and I don't do it.
I don't do it in my adult
years because I don't want to.
I don't,
I,
it doesn't turn me on.
And for a lot of reasons,
I just don't want to be part of it.
But you're married.
Well,
yeah,
but even if I wasn't married,
I wouldn't do it because
I have my own spot.
You want someone to be attracted to?
You don't know what it is.
I don't want to contribute to
someone else's destruction.
There are a lot of reasons.
I have a philosophy behind it.
It doesn't matter.
But,
but,
um,
I come out of,
uh,
Jimmy Burke's apartment.
It's late at night.
I am literally been on a plane and I,
these,
these two blondes were in a car and I
look in and I go and they go high and I
go,
hi,
what are you doing?
I go,
not much,
and Emilia,
I'm like,
hmm,
interesting.
And I figured,
man,
I think I don't know what
they look kind of Hungary.
And they go,
you want to have a good time nine ago?
How much?
And they go,
how much do you have?
And I go,
I don't know,
$5,000 how's that sound like?
That's silly.
Right?
Right.
So they go,
sounds great.
We'll be right here.
I go,
okay,
I'm going to go right to the bank machine
and she can't give five now that can
be seen by the way to get to cash.
I had no cash to get in a cab and go home.
Guess what?
I go to the bank,
Shane guess was waiting for me.
Bunch of cops.
Guess what those calls were?
Cops.
It was a sting operation and they
caught me and I looked the cubs and go,
you guys are really going to arrest me.
I said,
$5,000 guy goes,
yeah,
I know that.
Here's the problem.
You got caught up in the suite.
We've got to take in sat next to a guy
who was dressed like a woman who was
trying to pick up women and
he was peeling his knee.
He was so nervous.
He was peeling his a nail Polish off.
I spent two days in jail.
It was a lot of fun and I
thank God there were there to protect
and serve and a class for John's for um,
where I had to go to a class for a,
you know,
whatever.
Like you know,
for John John's,
for people that this is also a story
you should be telling on stage.
Right.
Kind of funny way to do it.
Well,
it's just unbelievable.
Yeah.
Busted.
Trying to pick up prostitutes.
Someone can what come up to you and ask
you if you want to have a good time and
then when you respond to that.
But especially to show the cops were cool.
They were like,
Bro,
I mean look for me,
by all means,
I get it.
The problem is you got caught up
in the sweep in and they were like,
don't worry about it.
They're like,
it'd be knocked down to
a misdemeanor just to,
it's a pain in the ass.
I know.
They were all cool.
I mean,
you know,
but,
but you were in jail for two days.
That's not a misdemeanor and I had to
make up a story up next to you in a car
and say shit like that.
You got to know that they'll park.
They were parked like music,
video type shit.
That shit don't exist.
It does exist though.
That's the problem you hear about and
fucking penthouse letters and maybe this
is the time I was getting married the
next day or something and my wedding would
be over.
I mean there's all kinds of shit
I just learned when girls go,
Oh,
you want a party?
They're not talking about
dancing to some tunes as well.
Do a little drugs.
Hats with rubber bands at the bottom.
Yeah,
they're not talking about
celebrate two times in Vegas.
I got,
I got had with a girl,
met her.
She's cute.
We're talking,
hanging out gets get upstairs and we
started kissing and she goes and I started
moving.
She goes,
oh wait,
hold on,
hold on.
You have no idea how
much fun this could be,
but nothing's free.
I was like,
aw,
you got me.
Then another girl,
we were hanging dancing,
beautiful,
having a great time.
Kissy Kissy,
go to my room and she goes,
oh,
the problem is I have to go to work.
I go,
oh wow.
What do you mean what didn't work where?
Almost like meg.
She goes,
well,
it cost me $1,000 you know,
I'll lose it.
Thousand dollars tonight if I don't dance.
I was like,
you want $1,000 I kicked
her out of my room.
You 100% gave her.
I didn't.
I was like,
I really didn't.
I'd be like,
you know what?
I'm just going to grow.
We take check and of course she like,
no,
actually take credit cards.
I didn't like the way she did it.
I just didn't like the way she was
trying to pull a fast one on me.
That is hilarious.
I was like,
you gotta be careful these days.
These hoes ain't loyal
their John.
You know,
John,
my real problem with all of it is
when you make something illegal,
it puts all this extra energy in
something because you create consequences.
The consequences being
you could go to jail,
crime,
you know,
all sorts of issues can happen.
It's a,
is it a,
it's a misdemeanor.
So as a prostitution,
right,
that's not a felonies.
She still get knocked down to carry
a gun and you could still vote,
but either way,
the idea behind her,
they're taking what your freedom
and putting you in the system.
You also probably have to register
as some sort of a sex offender
dates.
You do.
I had a bed in some states
in Calabasas for sure.
For sure.
You're not a street man.
I mean it depends on what
the fuck you're doing.
You know,
like what are you doing with the
prostitute and you get this figured out.
You're still making a fire from your
job and kind of big consequences.
Here's the point is in countries like
Australia where they have legalized
prostitution,
they're divorce rate is way lower.
Sure.
They don't have like all this
violent crime and prostitution need.
First of all the,
with the violent crime,
they don't need John's.
Okay.
They work in these places where they
have security to get people tested.
When people walk through the door,
they know,
you know they take their id.
Sounds like the way to go.
We're going to do it regardless.
It show me GP legal fuck someone for free,
which it is.
Why isn't it legal to
fuck someone for money?
What's the difference?
If it's legal to give
someone a massage for money,
why isn't it legal to stick to [inaudible]
guys consensual and all free him free
me to consensual adults and
all my nerve endings are,
they're two consenting adults in all
my nerve endings and I want to relax.
I can't let the guy problems jam his
ring finger right up my shit or strong
lower back issue I do.
You can't have him jam his ring finger
and his middle finger right up my shit or
yeah,
couple of digits.
No matter what that opening again,
three knucks deep.
Well it's,
it's,
I always bring it back to if there was,
if this room,
okay the five of us in this room,
if we were the only
people on earth and uh,
for whatever reason and then you know
the people and there was like four of the
prostitutes and you know,
w w would one of us arrest the other
one and lock us in jail for having sex
aside.
How new laws the law about the restaurant,
about how crazy that would
be if it was four of us.
And one of us said,
I mean it was really,
you only met on the planet and what we
found out Brent and found out that you
were having sex with
prostitutes and he's like,
I've got to bring in Bro,
I got to bring you.
And you're like,
what?
He's got some crazy cage set
up with bamboo fucking bars,
some fucking lost cage
on an island somewhere.
Cause we're the only people like you
can't have prostitution in the civilized
world.
That's it.
Well,
it's just as ridiculous.
If there's 400 million,
it's just as ridiculous a grown
adult telling another grown adult,
whether it's male or female,
what they can do or do that harms
no one.
The woman makes a decision whether for
whatever reason decides she wants to have
sex with a man and she
wants to get paid for it.
The man makes a decision.
He decides,
I'm tired of dealing with this bullshit.
I don't want a relationship.
I just want to pay for sex.
And these women,
they pretend that they liked
me and they really don't.
So I'll just give them what they want.
Which is money,
right?
That for guys who are unattractive,
that is the only way bang hot shit.
It's easier to control.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
Have a personality.
It's easier to control people even that
are married with kids than single dudes
banging prostitutes.
You can't control those dudes.
Yeah,
you can't.
So you've got to make that shit illegal.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
It's illegal.
It's amazing.
It's a pure technical law.
It goes back to,
you know,
it's stupid.
It's a stupid law.
This is,
you know,
you don't want your daughter
Toby man doing prostitution.
I don't want my daughter
doing prostitution.
But the reality is people are
going to have sex with people.
And one of the reasons why prostitution
has a stigma attached to it is the
legality of it.
That's the one of the main reasons.
It's just we're all for it.
We're fucking weird with sex man.
Varying things always happened.
I think it goes back though,
I think it goes back to the kinds of
diseases we didn't have cures for.
I think about antibiotics only
been around for about 60 years,
maybe even less.
I mean,
when you got syphilis and gonorrhea
and you got other diseases,
it was no joke.
Oh No,
no one knew.
If you're a stigma,
there was a stigma too.
Especially syphilis.
She went crazy.
I mean,
I mean you did.
I mean there was a stigma to sexual,
uh,
liberal sexual activity
because it was in many cases,
very unhealthy in the way these systems
in like some kind of institution.
Well,
that's what happened.
How could you do?
That's what happened at
alcohol and people die.
What happened in Nietzsche,
Nietzsche would became simplitic.
I mean a lot of things,
modern days,
celebrities coming down with,
well now they hit you with antibiotics.
Penicillin actually
clears it up right away.
You got a shot in your ass.
They can cure that shit quick.
But until penicillin came along,
syphilis was awful because what happened
was you would get Soren from your deck.
No,
I don't think so.
So on the end of your deck
and then you would go then,
then incubate for a long time,
like 10 years and then you would
start to lose your fucking mind.
There's no way can incubator
for 10 fucking years.
There is a way in.
It did.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot know about it could
be in your body for a long time.
Yeah.
That was the thing about HIV was that
the incubation people see the incubation
period is what scared the fuck out of it.
What about that teaching is on HIV counts.
Really interesting because of the
protease inhibitors and stuff.
It's had to mutate so many times that it
actually has weakened itself that make
so many compromises.
You born at a time come it,
right?
No HIV,
you're straight.
You believe that Michael Jordan's the
virus is actually weakened over time.
You have to listen to this radio
lab podcast called patient zero.
It's fucking amazing.
It's amazing because they
tracked HIV from the top.
They used to have this guy
they thought was patient
zero.
He was a gay guy that was having sex
with all these people and he knew that he
was infected with it was the early days
of aids in America for like in the 1980s
and everybody thought this guy was patient
zero and he was infecting all these
people.
Then they found out they
trace the lineage back.
I want to encourage everybody,
if you haven't listened to radio lab,
it's a fucking amazing podcast.
It's so good.
It's so consistently good and really
well produced and really well edited.
It's genius.
And they had this,
um,
this,
these doctors,
the scientists that
traced the lineage of the,
the,
the disease,
they brought it all the way back
to the early 19 hundreds monkeys,
well the rig,
they will,
will,
they brought it all the way back to the
early 19 hundreds in America and then
they brought it all the way back to uh,
even earlier than that in Africa.
It came from a hunter and the,
the number one theory is a cut hunter
like a hunter because in Africa they kill
a lot of monkeys.
They eat them,
you know,
their,
they call it Bushmeat,
they'll kill monkeys and chimps and
that someone killed a monkey or a chimp.
And that champ,
as they were cutting it,
they cut themselves and they got the
blood in the cut and that chimp had killed
a neat and two different types of
monkeys that had two different types of
infectious diseases.
So different types of virus,
two different types of
immune if immunodeficiency,
diseases.
And those two mutated inside that chimps
body and then got into a person and
then it became loud and know how hard
that is to believe that they nailed that
shit down to subdue,
to go listen.
If you listen to the podcast,
they explain the lineage,
they explain how they did it is,
and it is fascinating.
Also isolated.
Yeah.
Which I thought was fascinating.
Why didn't HIV,
why was it a disease,
a heterosexual disease in Africa and not
an in among your northern Europeans and
Europeans in general?
Well,
it didn't make any sense.
They kept thinking as our
secondary infections and
stuff and what they found was
that anybody of European lineage,
black plague,
right?
Yeah.
If you survive the black played,
you had a mutation in your gene that
made you resistance to the HIV virus,
which is wild and they've isolated that.
And so what's really wild is like I'm
always encouraged people to read a book
called why evolution is true.
Evolution is true by Jerry Coyne and
he's at an evolutionary biologist and a
man.
When you really look at the science
of how they isolate these things.
When they look at the genome and they
look at like what they can read on a gene
like viruses,
that word that that were dormant,
that you,
you share the same kind
of viruses that uh,
you're,
you're like ancestors,
your monkey ancestors did
really fascinating stuff.
The overwhelming evidence,
like as we learn more about evolution,
it becomes more true,
not less true,
which is fascinating to me.
So there,
there are a lot of things
when then evolution,
but the whole HIV thing,
you know,
I listened to Duisburg and that guy,
rex is a good for him.
Yeah.
You know what man?
A lot of sense.
Yeah.
But here's the problem.
It doesn't make sense to biologist,
not a biologist.
He doesn't make sense to viral ologists.
He doesn't make sense to any of the
researchers that have been working for
decades.
If it was a really,
I thought I was with you before I talked
to Duisburg and then talk to other
scientists about it.
And if it was a real issue where they
really couldn't understand the differences
between with Duesberg was saying and
with other biologists are saying it would
make sense,
but it's,
it's out there.
All the information's out
there and it's hotly disputed.
Like Duesberg is wrong about so many
different things about how viruses behave
and about HIV in general
on a specialty man.
Yeah.
It's,
I'm pretty convinced that he made some
pretty critical errors in the early days
of HIV and then stayed with
that also testify with Maddie.
Yes.
Wrath.
Matty.
His wrath who was pushing his vitamins
on South Africans and telling them not to
go with regular um,
uh,
produce protocols and he said,
take my vitamins and that's
how you'll cure your disease.
HIV and Duesberg was with him when he
testified and you can see the people in
that.
They were talking about the people that
working on the ground with these things
and they were like
shaking their head going,
this guy has an ego.
He just flew in.
He has no idea what we're dealing with.
He doesn't know.
He's just not see what we're
dealing with on the ground.
He doesn't see the kind of the kind
of disaster we're dealing with.
The health crisis disaster and watching
people die and get sick and stuff and
this Guy Duesberg is coming
in and testifying that
that wells well of Duisburg
is wrong.
Then we basically stopped aids,
like aids was going to be a
thing that affected in the nut.
If the in the 80s when you heard
all the predictions one out,
a lot of people are hit dot four but
they predicted one out of four people
between the ages of 18 and
35 something like that.
It was going to be,
it was going to be like the black plague
and if Duesberg is wrong then man we'd
licked aids.
When you say that,
like people saying that,
you know who was saying that shit
the media and you know the media,
if it bleeds it leads.
Anything that's controversial it
everybody was going to die but everybody's
going to be talked to
health like nationals.
A lot of people,
first of all,
did die in Africa a lot and and
a lot of people in this country.
Do you know what is killed?
Half of the people that
have ever died ever wait,
wait,
malaria.
I was going to say I,
the malaria is a mother familiar by far.
It kills more than a million people year.
Malaria kills the shit out.
I everybody.
That's why Bill Gates
was so instrumental in,
and he said,
what you really need is mosquito nets.
Yeah.
I had a dude on my podcast
that had fucking malaria.
I've seen it.
I've seen malaria with my own eyes.
I've seen somebody suffer from that.
Malaria is terrifying.
I was a kid.
I went from the mosquitoes.
You shake your so called Ooh,
and you could fucking die easy.
A lot of people die from a good
percentage of the people that get malaria.
Dot.
Ebola is another one.
Both fucking terrifying.
What do you think about this Ebola shit
that's been going on in the last couple
of months?
Pretty contagious.
You
know what,
man,
there's a bunch of shit that's going on.
It's not hype.
It's,
it's real.
It's contagious as fuck.
Cause AIDS workers are getting it.
People that are giving people
that are medical people,
aid workers,
people that are medical
professionals are getting it.
So you know,
they,
they're dealing with situations
that we're trying to help people.
And you're around people all the time
because they figured out a way to close it
off in the United States.
It's so very few cases
of dying for me.
Bolas so I mean the chances,
I mean other countries in other countries,
if you get it,
it's almost a death sentence.
Right?
But in America it's about 40% 40%
of the people that get American men,
it's very hot.
But 40% of the people,
the people that have all come
over from Africa that had had it,
they're all fine.
Yeah.
They all know they were talking about it.
They were trying to isolate why some
people survive and others don't.
They actually don't know.
They think it is genetic.
They think you had to have
a genetic resistance to it.
Where because typically the overall,
if you look at the grants statistic 70
you got a 70% chance I believe of dying.
If you get Ebola.
If you look at the broad statistic,
something like that,
what are the odds that the
Ebola thing all over the news?
It was a distraction from like let's
say Syria is that that I don't think the
news can work that way because there's
so many different independent outlets,
so many different independent in remember
let people on the ground like the
doctors that are going there and
making no money and just going there.
That's where we're getting
a lot of our information.
We're also getting our information from
mostly health workers aren't getting our
information from CNN and Fox News turned
to get America to panic all the time.
There's a possibility
that's all a distraction.
I think the media makes
money by sewing fear I think.
I think the meaning.
You don't think the media is controlled
by whoever's running everything.
You think that people that are
running everything half don't.
I think think about control too
complicated and there are too many other
interests for anybody to run everything.
For example,
take the administration,
take a pray,
take a presidency.
First thing any president
always says what?
I had no car.
I had no control,
no power.
Why so many different people in
his cabinet have different agendas.
Everybody's undermining everybody and so
I think it's very difficult for any one
group to take total control
and they usually get found out.
I just think the media usually eat out.
Typically.
What do you,
what do you think?
I think that you can't trust,
it's not a bad,
you see a CNN Fox,
I think everything that's coming through
the major news that works all have an
agenda behind it.
Whether it's district,
because if I was running shit,
I would,
if I was wearing this shit and they said,
hey,
what do you think we should do?
I'm like,
wait a minute.
Are you guys controlling the media?
First of all,
if they say no,
we're not really controlling the media.
They do whatever they want.
I would say control the goddamn media.
What the fuck are you guys,
how would you control
me to explain to me how,
how do you think you
would control the media?
For example,
like the Ebola thing for example,
like,
like when you have all those
different people dying,
right?
And you have people getting more
people dying than the Fluor you,
no,
no.
But,
but Ebola same.
Devastating.
Exactly.
Because Evil Ebola is,
his heart is very difficult to
cure and probably a uncurable.
And also because it's so devastating
and it's so contagious and it,
and it spreads like wildfire because a
lot of these people who were there were,
were when their loved ones was sick,
they would take care of their loved
one and they would absorb the fluid.
And why isn't the news covering all the
innocent women and children dying in
these Middle Eastern
countries through US bombs?
Why are they not covering that?
Well,
I think they are.
They're not.
I think,
I think that sometimes
the news can be sanitized.
And I agree with you.
But what I'm saying is that I think,
and I agree that I think
that how many people die,
right?
On the trust.
How many people died in Iraq?
I don't know.
But a lot over 1 million civilians.
Over 1 million civilians.
A lot of different,
I've heard a lot of 1 million.
How many people have died of Ebola?
Not many fucks.
Zach thousand
over 1 million civilians died in Iraq.
You don't hear you heard about that?
They're not covering that.
That's,
that's a holocaust right there.
Why aren't we,
uh,
aiding the families,
families of these people?
Why aren't we talking about this?
No,
we're talking about some.
So to me,
to me,
if I was running shit,
I would have the media
on motherfucking lock.
I would have the movie industry
on lock out out of the TB easy.
The CIA's been in checking scripts since
the 50s to make sure that communism
doesn't infect,
Louise has no say and
could never tell a studio.
That's ridiculous.
You don't know that.
You're not a what?
When?
One of the things about wikileaks and
one of the things about finding out more
about what kind of information the CIA,
uh,
or what kind of a operations
CIA has been involved with.
They've been involved with the
influence of Hollywood movies forever.
Operation mockingbird
operation mockingbird is a real
jerk.
A lot of these guys,
these guys,
God's first of all want to be patriots.
A lot of these guys,
he's producer assholes that
are involved in these movies.
Studios.
They also,
they want access to information.
It's going to allow them to
make a very realistic film.
They want the government to be behind it.
So if you're doing a movie like on,
you know,
fill in the blank,
Black Hawk down,
so shit,
they got in trouble because there
are dark 30 a lot of people in the
intelligence community got in
trouble because it was so real.
And a lot of those things,
the,
the intelligence community
didn't want exposed.
I don't,
I don't mean there's
no,
you're,
you're saying Hollywood is,
if it's one guy,
it's not one guy.
You're talking about dozens of students,
parents and producers,
money coming from all sorts
of different directions,
a lot of it foreign,
you know,
so you,
by saying the CIA had one problem with
one film discrediting CIA influence on
Hollywood is kind of like
CIA has influenced this,
but what do you like,
how about there's a great
article in the Guardian.
There's a one,
uh,
there's,
there's a great article on
global research called lights,
camera action,
the deep politics of Hollywood.
And it's,
uh,
it's,
I mean there's just not just one thing.
Ron Howard wanted to make a movie,
I doubt very much.
And the runners in the essence,
I doubt very much their list,
the CIS coming and saying,
hold on guys,
you can't do this.
You already talking
about what you're saying.
Like they're,
you're company.
You're the CIA is telling those guys.
The CIA is telling us guys
what they can and can't do.
The CIA,
yes,
they're controlling how you,
okay,
listen,
Harry Anslinger was the first
drugs are in the United States.
He's single handedly responsible.
If you've done the research of ah,
making marijuana,
putting it into a schedule,
one category,
Harry Anslinger,
he was the one guy who was,
who was standing in front of Congress
with fake newspaper report that stated,
Look,
Congress,
we've got an outlaw,
this dangerous drug called marijuana.
It's making people listen.
Nobody's that gullible.
I mean,
I'm not,
you're not.
Wow.
You see?
You just don't know.
Listen,
listen,
Harry Anslinger was the guy responsible
for marijuana after marijuana's
prohibition.
He got into investigating or
looking into Hollywood scripts.
He was in charge of making sure
that communist screenwriter
shirt weren't trying
to brainwash the public.
That's right.
So the CIA McCarthy era,
they never pulled out.
You think they pulled out once
you're in your fucking name,
you think they pulled out Eddie?
I can.
I can write.
I can write anything I want.
Criticize him.
They pulled out.
You think they're told
that they got in it?
Everybody was,
have a conversation.
I can make a movie.
Yeah,
I can make a movie criticizing the CIA,
right?
No,
you can.
You're telling me that I couldn't do that.
You can't.
It.
Depending on how you criticize them,
they will come down at you.
They will knock on your
fucking door and talk to you.
That's what they will do.
That just turn on your fucking
laptop camera and kitchen beaten off.
Kidding.
Are you kidding?
They were in.
It's a fact that they were in Harry
Anslinger was the guy who brought in the
government to inspect the scripts to
make sure there was no communist plot.
You think they put him so,
so,
so does the CIA control the news
outlets know it had established an
entertainment liaison office,
which would collaborate in a strictly
advise a Tori advisory capacity with
filmmakers.
They would be idiots if they didn't.
If they didn't and they
brought me in the CIA,
80 medical,
you motherfuckers got the fuck out.
You guys were in and you got out.
How retirement are you?
Have you talked to the New
York Times editorial board?
They would laugh you out
of the room if you said,
oh,
I don't.
I don't know if they control everything.
What I think both fluids.
Hold on Eddie.
Come on,
man.
I think they've had some influence on
some movies because especially movies
about the agency themselves,
they've been consulted and
national security secrets.
You can't,
wanting to make sure that
they know how to you look.
If you're a guy and you live in Hollywood
and you have no history at all in in
secret service or anything,
you want to know how the
fuck things word right.
How does it work?
What?
What kind of a conversation does the
president have if they're were about to
drop a bomb on somebody,
what happens if someone is
trying to kidnap the president,
his family?
What?
What steps take place if we are going to
plant a phony dictator in place or you
know,
so there is without a
doubt some discussion.
I mean they've had some discussion
of us had been laid bare,
haven't they in this past like look
at how bad they look with this torture
report from,
from the intelligence committee.
I have a Mike big way.
What do you think of that?
Because the CIA was,
is is the one everyone blames?
It's okay.
The people above the theater,
they're like playing the Thea.
I looked at CIO,
so the CIO has different directors.
They keep rotating.
Nobody's accountable for anything.
It's just CIA,
the CIA's,
but you know what?
The Iran Contra Contra scandal with
George Sr was the vice president was the
head of the CIA,
became vice president.
There was a assassination attempt on
Ronald Reagan who is known as one of the
most oblivious,
dumb,
dumbest presidents.
Only second to George W and
George singer becomes president.
The head of the the the CIA,
his father Prescott Bush started the CIA,
his father,
Prescott Bush finance the
Nazis through union bank.
That's not a conspiracy theory that,
oh wait,
hold on.
And also knowledge on
notes.
So it's the CIO.
You're saying it's not the CIA,
there's somebody.
The CIA is just this,
the whipping boy.
There's nobody accountable in this
who's really running this shit.
Then who knows the people
with all the money,
the Rockefellers,
JP Morgan on the international bankers,
but the CIS,
perfect.
The CIO has been busted many times.
The CIO has been busted,
Bro,
that you listen to Rick Ross.
The CIA is the biggest drug
dealer in the United States.
How crazy is that?
That's not a conspiracy theory.
They brought over $5 billion a
coke in the 80s feel Brazilian,
all those drug cartels and
all the little drug [inaudible]
it on the news in Mexico,
in Juarez and all that shit.
That's a distraction.
Meanwhile,
the CIS bringing him coke by the military.
This is not conspiracy theory.
You don't see anything wrong with that.
Ronald Reagan and Nancy Reagan
dare to keep kids off drugs.
Yet the vice president of
bringing in all the drugs to MENA,
Arkansas,
bill vice president is bringing in drugs.
I like.
He's
busted.
His legs are almost off.
George senior got busted all
over north Iran Contra 1980
that was about Steven.
That was,
that was about bringing
drugs in selling arms.
Well busted.
It's a fact.
That wasn't the con.
The Iran Contra scandal
wasn't actually about drugs,
guns and drugs.
The drugs,
they got busted
selling.
Real question is how far up does it go?
The guy who was getting
the drugs to Rick Ross,
who was he actually being green liberal,
dropping off the gloves and
Mena Arkansas bill officers.
Is it the head of the CIA?
That's where it gets you say,
why would the CIA do that for money?
They can make us about money finance,
the Iran Contra,
he hit in the haunt,
the CIA,
the CIA had and getting all the money
they want from us because they do
whatever.
No,
they,
yeah,
but they don't because they have to do,
you know what their budget,
they have to prove to
them
that they weren't with this.
I ran out booking,
so hold on.
So,
so,
so let's say they sell drugs
and they get that money.
Yeah.
Okay.
So they played hard.
They did it illegally.
Right,
of course.
Okay,
so now,
now hold on.
Who,
what do they do with that cash?
I mean,
you're right.
We don't know what they do with it,
so fuck it.
It's not real.
I'm just saying that the CIA
is such a big bureaucracy,
so you need their tent and everything
they do basically is under civilian
control.
I mean,
I'm just saying technically.
Yeah.
Right.
So what's the word they
get as many they get,
they get,
they,
the Senate intelligence
committee gives them any,
pretty much they went outside to check.
They have a lot of money.
That's not true.
They don't get all the money for through
Congress that they get it all black ops
style.
They sell drugs,
sell arms.
That's what they do.
Have ovens that it's already,
it's an it's buff to just Google it.
Look it up.
Google,
Iran Contra.
They got busted and the
crazy thing about that,
not only did George senior get
busted doing it as a vice president,
but he became president.
He got Boston and then the dude,
he didn't get busted.
He got busted,
but nobody gets indicted.
Nobody is held accountable.
Well,
all of the waste of time they put up
all over north.
When you say busted,
like in what way was he busted?
Busted.
Everybody knows that,
looks into it and and doesn't
trust the fucking government.
They go,
you fucking criminal.
He's a criminal.
There's a criminal or all the
press and throw a criminal.
You can't be a president
unless you're a criminal.
I understand that.
But when you say busted,
like what specifically points to the
fact that George Bush was involved in
selling drugs?
He was,
his boss was George Sr.
He was the vice president.
Everything was wanting towards,
Oliver North has never
said anything about drugs.
I'll never admitted that he
was an art of selling drugs.
What do you think?
I don't know.
But the point is when you say busted,
like if you're going to point,
like if you were in a court
of law and you said this,
you said that he was mentioned drugs
and when they didn't go to jail for
murdering a Nicole,
but we,
we know he did it right.
Don't do,
do believe that he did or didn't.
Well this is a really distorted argument
though because you know when you say
George Bush was busted for selling drugs
or George Bush was busted for enabling
Oliver North to let drugs
go through south central La,
I don't really think he was,
I mean it would,
did he have anything to do with it?
If the CIA had something to do with drugs
and they use that money to fund the,
you know,
theory conscious versus
using that money for our list
hill on a boat they got caught.
Who want to believe that shit.
You can believe it then nobody,
nobody will ever be
accountable for that shit.
No one gets thrown in prison for that.
Show me just note on the message board
that we need to fight companion for this
fight companion.
No
gets accountable for shit.
CIA agent,
uh,
true both for freezing the restaurant.
Hey listen,
he Howard a a who for years defended the
CIA against any involvement in the JFK
assassination for years.
He our,
and he was involved in Watergate as well.
Very well known,
high level CIA for years.
What's the one guy in the,
in those documentaries about
the JFK conspiracy theory?
He,
how does,
like you all ain't got no proof.
What do you guys got?
You know,
he was killed by a lone nut,
uh,
the Harvey Oswald on his deathbed.
He said that was all bullshit.
He goes,
listen,
it was audience think CIA guy.
His bed confessions.
First of all,
I've never seen it.
Have you ever seen a
video of the deathbed?
You're saying some crazy shit.
There's many interviews
where he was dying.
He was like he dude,
and it's never made any of
this he hour to like the guy.
But if you've seen it was
he fucked up confession.
You tell me the two minutes.
It's two minutes,
but there's okay,
hold on.
See minutes of it.
Heady.
C'Mon man.
If if people are old they like,
they get delusional.
I'm going to say some crazy shit.
No lie.
Anyways,
I mean listen,
I'm not sure if it's true.
You know what?
You're right.
I believe you guys it,
we say let's get,
let's watch two and a half minutes.
If
you listened to him and then you tell me
with your judgment of if this guys like
this guy is a high level CIO.
Let me ask you a question
I didn't ask you.
Let me ask you one question.
Do you believe,
I
don't believe in anything.
I'm just trying to smell question.
I'm just trying to appreciate
it that you just love you.
I love you and you are.
But here's what I always,
when whenever you guys like and,
and you,
you know,
you'll have a guy you're
talking about who,
who admits all of these things
and there's video on it that,
the only thing that I
always go back to is this.
There are so many
investigative journalists,
so many who are good people who
are trying to find the truth.
A lot of people,
I mean if you look at the
New York Times and economist,
let me just,
let me just listen to NPR,
New York Times,
The economist,
Wall Street Journal,
these people don't make a lot of money,
but they do go to countries.
They risked their own lives and they,
they are as concerned with the truth
and exposing the truth as they,
as anybody.
A lot of going to amber Lyon.
But hold on,
hold on,
on,
and,
and what happens the way
the way an editorial board
works is when you go and you
say,
here's my story.
The first thing your editor
says in a credible newspaper,
like the economist is the oldest magazine.
How do you know this?
How do you know what's the first night?
I said,
I know a lot of journalists I've
interviewed and I've interviewed,
the first thing we say is
what the first thing they say,
let them finish man.
And the first thing they say is what
you need at least I believe it's three
credible sources that we can check
up on before we can run a newspaper,
uh,
Max.
And they're very careful about that.
Okay.
And so,
so when you have that much information
and you have the mainstream media,
which is the economist that
NPR that makes no money,
they rely on public funding and stuff
when everybody is essentially sharing the
same story and checking these things out.
These guys are so credible.
But they are,
I mean,
so you were saying that these journalists
that are risking their lives are,
are lying and you're one guy
is the one who has the truth.
That's what you're talking about.
Some black and white.
This one,
I said that there's,
there's one guy who has all the truth.
I said that this one guy will do,
and these journalists that you'll
know so well aren't full of shit.
I believe you that you,
all these journals that you
know aren't full of Shit.
You're talking about what
journalists with the,
with the,
with the CNN ask them is give
me three credible sources.
You don't know that yet.
How do you know that CNN,
he's talking about the times you want to,
but what really I think
the reality is that uh,
the major networks are full of shit.
The government at the high levels is
solely corrupt and you could just follow
the money and find out
how corrupt everyone is.
And the people at the top and politics
are not waking up thinking about what can
I do for the people.
They're not thinking about that shit.
They're thinking about how I keep
my power and how I make money.
That's my guests.
I don't believe any of
those mother fuckers.
So you don't think anybody is in the news?
I didn't say anybody.
Okay.
But you don't think the majority of
journalists have have the interest of the
truth in mind?
You think I'm being paid by somebody else.
Phone.
Do you ever read the New York Times?
Have you ever read the New
York Times or the economist or,
or do you listen to NPR?
Do you listen to,
do you read in The Wall Street Journal?
Did you ever I watch CNN.
Do you read those identifications?
I don't.
I don't watch CNN on a regular basis
because I feel that I'm getting fed an
agenda.
Okay.
Every now and then I'll watch it.
Why would I re read the New York Times?
I think that the people at the
top have all that shit on lock.
So why would I waste my time?
The only time I do read New York
Times or watch the CNN report,
I'm always watching and going,
what are these motherfuckers,
what is their agenda and how are they
trying to steer the public into a certain
opinion?
I don't believe,
I think they're all fucking corrupt.
I think they're all full of shit
and it's been like that for 35 40
at all.
And I think you're,
I think that's very arrogant to conciliate
think that you somehow have the truth
and all these people,
well,
I never
have the truth and shakers.
Are you using like mechanisms to fuel
your argument instead of it's fun.
I'm not using anything.
I'm not sure.
I'm just saying you will.
You just did his,
his death because he never said that
you have all the truth that when people,
I love people.
You're saying all these journalists,
Howard Hunt's deathbed confession and
we were talking about the CIA's admitted
role in Hollywood.
You tend to like not want to
buy into any of that stuff.
I tend to be the middle ground,
so we,
what we have is the mama bear,
papa bear,
baby bear.
I'm the middle there
because my podcast host is
you times 10 he will not,
he think he was day.
He'll say stuff like that.
He will say stuff like,
trust me,
I know the government's full of shit.
I know that.
It's always been that way.
I know that,
that they're fucking us.
I know that.
But he says that and then
he believes no conspiracy,
government conspiracy theories.
So it's kind of weird.
So it's way more over the top.
The new,
I think for me the fun
is Brian reads.
Yeah.
And you know what,
Zach reads a lot
to educate yourself.
Grind.
Zach reads a lot of books too.
Dude.
Zach,
the problems that might be the problem,
right?
That I think is that sometimes when we,
and we all do this,
when we,
um,
we decide that this is the enemy,
right?
When we go,
well,
for example,
I don't believe any of this.
I'm not going to read any of this.
And I think they're all,
you know,
are,
most of them are,
are not trustworthy.
I think that you do several of the surface
in some ways because I think the real
enemy is,
is a lot less insidious
and a lot less glamorous.
And I think the real enemy for example,
is like,
let's just take campaign finance reform.
Uh,
which is probably the most important
thing to talk about the money in politics
and the way basically somebody in Congress
has to spend 40 to 60% of his time
calling people he doesn't know just
to get enough money to get reelected.
Now you got a problem.
Or for example,
here's a huge enemy
disagreeing with that at all.
Yeah.
And so in thousand
my,
yeah,
leafs in 2010 for example,
this is fascinating that we had
some real problems in this country,
some real challenges and the thing that
they were arguing about on the floor and
congress was swipe swipe
fees for a tms swipe fees.
Why?
Because you had corporate behemoths,
they were arguing about their bottom line
and influencing congress because they
wanted to make more money and they didn't
give a shit about the real issues that
faced you.
Me and the average person,
I guess what I'm talking about,
I've totally believe right and,
and but,
but remember now that was very,
very much dilated and really exposed
by some of the mainstream media is like
look for New York Times,
said some great stuff on that.
Lawrence Lessig who's a Harvard lawyer
and wrote a great book called Republic
loss.
So there's really great information out
there and if you know where to look,
I think that a lot of people in earnest
and a lot of great journalists do a
great job trying to expose
what the real enemy is.
And I'm always fascinated with the fact
that it's not even so much the CIA.
I though I'll say they come
out looking terrible in this,
what they did.
You know that he's 39 detainees and stuff,
but how many people were involved?
That's what I want to know.
We don't want to know,
like when you,
when you leave someone
alone with detainees,
like how many people are involved
in the decision to torture them,
how many people or shield themselves
from that to protect themselves?
They don't want to know.
They just want the information.
I wonder,
you know,
they did a five year study
and one of the things that,
one of the reasons to see I got caught
was because a lot of CIA officers were,
were sending emails back
to their superior saying,
I don't like this.
This is really bad.
Well,
you know,
arrested was the whistle blower.
The whistle blows and Jay,
the whistle blowers in jail.
Everybody else who fucking froze,
none of them.
None of them frozen stuff frozen.
Got It.
I did awful stuff.
And,
and,
and the other issue from what I understand
is that a lot of this world will
contract was subcontracted out,
put them in a room naked.
They chained him to a wall,
they changed the law and he
was naked and it was cold.
Yeah.
Anytime.
Died overnight.
And we don't really know,
by the way,
we don't really know how many people
this happened to and we don't know a lot.
Got To get that info.
Uh,
yes,
but I worked off does Eddie probably he
probably just for everyone else at home
and he probably just
went to Pete's fantastic.
He gets so worked up.
I was hoping you'd jump over here
and choke the shit out of room.
He loves conspiracy theories.
He gets upset if there's a rational,
I,
I hope he gets upset and I love him.
I love my Eddie Brock.
I don't see any bravo enough.
He loves his conspiracy theories.
I nobody loves conspiracy theories
nine 11 and you don't have educate him.
Unfortunately we don't
have any time out of time.
The Howard Hunt deathbed confession,
which is interviews with him,
talking about what really happened,
and Jeff,
Jeff K's assassination.
That's CIA agent telling you what
place on the map he's telling you,
but no one would that for Callan
real quick before you play.
You got to understand we're
not going to the basic,
I mean why not?
Why not?
We'll be able to show something
on that.
That's what I'm saying is
when you looked at JFK.
Yeah.
We don't have any time.
Okay.
All right.
You wouldn't want to hear,
I wanted to hit,
I wasn't here nine to 11 it's
deep like game of Thrones deep.
Jfk Is this deep and
complicated as game of Thrones.
Seriously,
you have this many members involved in
that assassination as game of Thrones.
The names,
the how they affected the SASA nation.
Everything.
It's so deep.
If you look into it,
it's so deep.
It's fucking insane how deep it is and
how deep the CIA was involved in it.
It's very widely known.
It's not a conspiracy theory that Jed
Kate did not support the CIA's invasion,
the Bay of pigs.
They did not.
They did cid fog operation 40 40
assassins to take out Fidel Castro.
The Bay of pigs was their
mission to go get Fidel Castro.
JFK didn't support them,
didn't support air support.
They lost the Bay of pigs.
The CIA wanted,
was so pissed at JFK.
JFK fired the director of the CIA,
Allen Dulles fire the director of the
CIA as a result of what happened in the
Bay of pigs.
So the CIS director is fired by JFK,
the whole operation.
40 40 elite international assassins
assigned and put together to kill Fidel
Castro.
The craziest assassins ever hate JFK.
The vice president Lyndon B Johnson was
about to be indicted for two murders.
Mac Wallace was his bodyguard
who murdered people for Lyndon.
B Johnson.
Lyndon B Johnson was a known gangster.
He mingled with the top mobster.
He was so,
and he,
he decided the budget on the CIA and
the FBI and it was really close to,
um,
uh,
j Edgar Hoover.
When you look at the,
what went down,
the only reason Lyndon B Johnson didn't
go to prison for two murders that he
ordered at Mac Wallace on to kill people.
He was a gangster was because Jeff died.
He became president and clean that out.
When you look at all that shit.
And then you also look at JFK in
his and his 33 months in office,
he had,
uh,
he had every month he
had a different mistress.
Every must one of his
[inaudible] was higher,
was quite as like this hustle.
Yeah.
Cord Meyer was one of the
top CIA guys back then.
JFK,
this was judge Kaye was
banging cored wires and wife.
So when you listen to this,
he,
Howard hunt concessional,
he said Lyndon B Johnson work
a straight at the whole thing.
He lives,
he's telling you a CIA agent famous on
his deathbed saying you'd look at it was
cord Meyer cord.
Meyer wanted him dead.
So Lyndon B Johnson,
he had cord.
Marie [inaudible] at the
time was Eddie Bravo,
spent smoking weed,
peering out curtain senior bars.
Why wouldn't you play
[inaudible]?
Don't have any time,
but we'll tell everybody to go to Brian.
Be Nice to play a fucking 11 o'clock.
But still,
if he's going to learn,
he's got alert Howard
[inaudible] why you fucker?
You should be like,
oh my God,
let me listen to this.
I don't believe
you're a smart guy.
This guy is breaking down
and several people on,
no news ever and this guy
is telling you how JFK went.
The fuck down.
He's telling you he was there.
He's telling you I was there.
He saying every assassin was there.
They all knew about it.
All operation 40 they
were dressed like bumps.
He said that.
He goes,
I wasn't involved in it,
but I was on the bench for the big event.
They called it the big event.
Everybody knew about it.
They all set up.
They were all involved in,
it was a huge game of Thrones thing,
gave me as a great TV show,
damage.
They have dragging Howard Hunt,
deathbed confession.
Time to play it for you.
We don't have time.
Do you go and you do your research?
He has anyone to look at it.
You don't want,
you don't want to learn.
I think the news cares about the people.
It's a straw man.
You can't really say that.
He never says that.
It's just he's,
he's talking about the ethics
of journalism and the importance
Kelly's wrong end of the day calendar.
The reality is neither does any of those.
Some information is very difficult
to acquire for journalists.
So they sent me information
about Seaberry seals.
When you,
when someone says Barry Seal's,
you know a lot about them,
right?
Barry Seal's without a doubt.
Listen to Lou drugs into Mena
Arkansas without a doubt.
And what Barry Seals was involved in the
murder of two kids that found a drop.
They found a drop of cocaine.
This guy was flying back and forth.
There's numerous pictures of him,
not just with CIA agents,
but with numerous known drug dealers
from South American Central America.
Without a doubt.
The pilot,
yes,
without a doubt.
That is older news.
But more recent news,
there was a CIA drug playing.
They'd been to Guantanamo Bay twice,
that crash of four tons of cocaine,
100% guaranteed verified fact.
A jet that had been to Guantanamo
Bay and been used by the CIA,
was guilty of transporting cocaine into
the United States crashed because the
Mexican authorities would
not let them refuel.
That's like,
you know what you seeing video that's
like you see in video of Joe Rogan's
sucking Dick and not believing he's gay.
[inaudible] relax,
relax.
You're not going to get it right.
It's a waste of fucking time
to even try no matter what.
It was like.
I don't hear that.
I'm frankly,
I'm sick.
Leave you
guys,
man.
Hey man,
you're jumping ship over here.
Oh yeah.
It feels good.
It feels good on this side.
Just to,
that's some serious shit.
The CIA got busted for,
for importing $5 billion
with a coke through MENA,
Arkansas,
while Bill Clinton was
the governor of Arkansas.
Why do you think he became president?
He was huge.
He was the governor of Arkansas,
allowing all this shit to happen.
Look at these photos.
This is hilarious.
This is the plane.
This is all the coke that
was on the plane for,
yeah.
This is the plane that crashed a calendar,
but it's not going to mean Shit the count.
He still believes that it's all cocaine.
Believes lamb four times.
Damn.
Just coke.
I want to know what you guys
seem about nine 11 I know.
We don't have time.
It's late,
but oh,
you motherfucker.
But inside job for sure.
1000000%.
I told him the other day,
Brian Calendars took off his headset.
Same with this guy.
Then I got to go home.
30 seconds,
30 seconds.
It's podcast is brought to you by on it.
Go To o.
N N.
I t.
Use a codeword Rogan.
Save 10% of any and all supplements.
You want to get some gangster coffee.
Can yourself some caveman coffee,
ladies and gentlemen,
Caveman Coffee company.com we've
been fucking drinking this shit.
The whole podcast.
Some of us more than others.
Dump on it.
Howard Hunt,
10th planet j J.
Dot Com Brian cowen.com
80 bravo on Twitter.
Brendan Schaub on Twitter.
Brian [inaudible] on Twitter during the
kid fighter and the kid podcast number
one across the board.
He Bravo radio drama creates listeners.
Eddie Bravo radio.
You want to hear more
on conspiracy theory?
Slash [inaudible].
Can't wait.
All right,
do it.
Come on.
A Sunday was a roofer.
We'll stay away from again.
Zack Waldman,
my Carlos,
he's,
he's worse than you.
He does.
He believes that a lot of ways.
Yeah.
Wear ear muffs.
You gotta take a beating.
I gave up on sac that no matter
what that science I give him,
he doesn't,
he doesn't want to hear it.
All right,
my friends,
let's do this again next time
I actually watched fights
two and a half.
Well we the fade or fucking Cro,
cop one was pretty bad at cro
cop Vandelay it was great.
So was a fade or those were great.
We'll do more of these,
man.
We can do these anytime and then they
turn into whatever the fuck they turned
on.
So we need to do again
to a whole nine 11 thing.
Cause you got to
understand this is not real.
You understand?
He's playing a role right now.
[inaudible] slash tongue in
cheek smilers Kotlin Jeez,
I don't know.
The CIA has sponsored this
podcast and it's now over.